voilà Mesdames Messieurs je vous propose
de commencer cette audition sous forme
de table ronde en nous excusant un petit
peu pour le léger retard voilà qui était
dû à l'audition précédente donc cette
table ronde elle est consacrée aux
sociétés d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique alors nous
recevons le groupement des
professionnels des certificats d'énergie
qui est représenté par Madame Florence
Liévin membre du bureau et responsable
des affaires publiques chez sonerja Elio
qui représenté par Monsieur Pierre Marie
Perrin son directeur des affaires
publiques et fi représentée par sa
directrice d'affaires stratégique madame
Audrey zermatti ainsi que par son
directeur des affaires publiques
monsieur romain Riom texial qui est
représenté par son directeur général
monsieur Jean-Baptiste de valent le
syndicat symbiote qui est représenté par
Sylvie charbonnier sa secrétaire général
et enfin Doremi qui est représenté par
Vincent Legrand président ainsi que par
Madame Léana miska qui est responsable
des affaires publiques je pense n'avoir
oublié personne vous pratiquez tous une
activité de conseil à la rénovation
énergétique et à l'efficacité
énergétique ou alors vous représentez
des sociétés qui sont positionnées sur
ce secteur et nous avons pu constater au
cours de nos différentes auditions le
rôle crucial que joue l'accompagnement
des ménages mais aussi des entreprises
dans la politique de rénovation
énergétique des logements
l'accompagnement est souvent
indispensable pour se repérer dans le
maquis des aides pour réaliser les
opérations qui sont les plus adaptées à
sa situation mais aussi pour éviter
autant de faire ce peu des fraudes
à cet égard le nouveau dispositif clé
mon accompagnateur rénove et
progressivement déployer depuis le début
de l'année dans quelle mesure avez-vous
été associé à sa conception
quel regard portez-vous sur ce
dispositif et avez-vous d'ores et déjà
des propositions pour l'améliorer si
votre action permet d'éviter les fraudes
à la rénovation énergétique des
personnes mal intentionnées peuvent au
contraire se faire passer pour des
accompagnateurs à la rénovation
énergétique pour cette raison des
mesures ont été prises ces dernières
années pour renforcer la lutte contre la
fraude comme par exemple
l'interdiction du démarchage
téléphonique dans le secteur de la
rénovation énergétique est-ce que ces
politiques ont eu un impact sur vos
activités est-ce que vous auriez pris
des mesures différentes pour assurer une
meilleure protection face à la fraude
l'accompagnement à ma rénovation
énergétique est aujourd'hui souvent
associée à ma prime rénove mais il ne
faut pas oublier qu'il y a aussi le
dispositif qui est plus ancien des
certificats d'économie d'énergie or les
C2E sont souvent mises en cause pour
leur complexité y compris pour les
publics avertis partagez-vous ce constat
et le cas échéant comment
appréhendez-vous cette complexité avant
de vous laisser la parole pour répondre
à cette première question et en
commençant par le c'est le gpc2e il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu
qui sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage de votre
commission d'enquête serait passible des
peines prévues aux articles 434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende à 100000 euros je vous invite
donc tour à tour à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
à lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure on commence peut-être par vous
madame Liévin
je le jure
je jure je le jure
merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup de donner la parole au gpc2e
rappeler en quelques mots ce qu'est le
gpc2e depuis 10 ans c'est l'association
représentative du groupement des
professionnels des certificats
d'économie d'énergie et plus
particulièrement des délégataires en
économie d'énergie le délégataire c'est
véritablement le trait d'union entre le
bénéficiaire et l'obliger donc un acteur
incontournable dans la chaîne du
traitement des certificats d'économie
d'énergie tout ça peut paraître un peu
complexe peut-être un point plus précis
les certificats d'économie d'énergie
rappelons-le correspondent au premier
mécanismes financier d'accompagnement de
la rénovation énergétique en France vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente ça fait
plusieurs années de nombreuses années
qu'il est en oeuvre et suivant le cours
on estime qu'il représente 5 à 6
milliards par an d'argent consacré à
l'efficacité énergétique l'ensemble de
ces financements ne vont pas directement
à la rénovation énergétique puisque six
secteurs découvert par ce mécanisme des
C2E mais on estime peu ouprou que trois
pardon c'est des milliards 3 milliards
sont consacrés par an à ce mécanisme des
C2E pour la rénovation énergétique à
mécanisme qui est souvent taxé de
complexité parfois aussi associé à de la
fraude à de l'écho délinquance vous
l'avez rappelé pour autant nos voisins
ne s'y sont pas trompés et je tiens
souligner que l'Espagne a très récemment
fait le choix en ce début d'année 2023
de choisir également pour financier
financer sa politique publique
d'accompagnement à l'efficacité
énergétique de retenir ce mécanisme des
certificats d'économie d'énergie une
fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est-ce qui nous
semble important à la fois par rapport
au sujet de l'accompagnement au sujet
des financements au sujet de la fraude
que vous avez mentionné plusieurs fois
le premier c'est celui de la lisibilité
le constat que nous faisons y compris en
tant que professionnel c'est que nous
sommes trop régulièrement perdu pourquoi
perdu du fait des changements qui sont
beaucoup trop fréquents que ce soit au
niveau des C2E de MPR ou des autres
mécanismes ce sont des changements qui
sont pluriannuels des changements qui
peuvent être même mensuels et donc nous
il nous semble en tout cas que pour
aller vers une efficience plus
importante de la politique publique de
rénovation énergétique il faudrait à
minima limiter à deux changements deux
évolution par an l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs et en l'occurrence qu'on ait
des mécanismes qui entre en vigueur et
ou qui s'arrêtent au 1er janvier de
chaque année et au 1er juillet et en
dehors de ces deux dates clés un peu
symbolique quelque part vraiment essayer
autant que faire ce feu se peut de ne
pas prendre d'autres dispositifs ça
permettrait vraiment une lisibilité et
plus d'efficacité le deuxième point
c'est l'harmonisation vous l'avez dit on
parle de ces deux œufs on parle de MPR
on on va rajouter les compétitz on
pourrait rajouter le prêt avancer
rénovation on pourrait rajouter les
aides des collectivités locales on
pourrait ma consœur en parlera elle
avait fait un état des lieux je crois
qu'il y avait 7 aides à la rénovation
énergétique à un moment il y en a
peut-être encore plus même maintenant
ces aides sont nécessaires et elles ont
finalement une source de financement et
des fonds qui sont différents et donc en
ce sens elle ne peuvent pas l'une
l'autre se substituer par contre elle
doivent être complémentaires et
absolument dans leur critères
d'éligibilité de délivrance et de
contrôle se rejoindre et ça c'est un
point fort qu'il est nécessaire de
travailler puisqu'à ce jour si on prend
la seule question de l'âge du bâtiment
sur certains dispositifs il faut que le
bâtiment ait plus de deux ans sur
d'autres il faut que le bâtiment est
plus de 15 ans si on prend la question
de la rénovation globale sur certains
dispositifs on entend rénovation globale
comme plus de 35% d'économie d'énergie
sur les 55% d'économie d'énergie c'est
beaucoup trop complexe pour être lisible
et amener à quelque chose d'efficace et
cohérent et le dernier point avant de
laisser la parole à mes confrères c'est
la question de l'égalité de traitement
il n'est pas possible pour nous d'avoir
une politique efficace de rénovation
énergétique si l'ensemble des acteurs
autour de la table ne se voit pas
appliquer les mêmes exigences là je
parle plus particulièrement au niveau
des producteurs de certificat d'économie
d'énergie dont les délégataires sont
l'une des composantes mais pas que
puisque on estime que les légataires
génèrent environ 30 à 40% des
certificats d'économie d'énergie les
autres certificats étant générés par les
mandataires et les obliger or à ce jour
seuls les délégataires se voient imposer
des contraintes légitimes on les remet
pas en cause au niveau du code de
l'énergie alors que finalement le but
est le même c'est de produire des C2E de
qualité à la fin or un C2E est un C2E
donc il n'est pas normal finalement que
tous les producteurs ne se fassent pas
appliquer les mêmes exigeantes et même
contraintes et donc nous avons la
certitude qu'en termes de qualité et en
termes de lutte contre la fraude il y
aurait là un pas en avant significative
à faire merci
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente donc je suis Pierre Marie
Perrin directeur des affaires publiques
de la société Elio Elio c'est 300
personnes 300 salariés le siège social
est basé à Paris et nous avons une
quinzaine d'implantations en région la
spécificité de notre entreprise nous
sommes multiccepteurs donc c'est à dire
que nous accompagnons autant les ménages
dans la rénovation énergétique de leur
maison individuelle mais nous
accompagnons également
l'habitat collectif les copropriétés les
bailleurs sociaux mais également toutes
les entreprises du tertiaire nous
accompagnons également l'industrie les
exploitations agricoles donc nous avons
un spectre assez large et nous voyons
également ceux qui fonctionnent bien
dans l'accompagnement des autres
secteurs d'activités comme le tertiaire
comme l'habitat collectif qui est
beaucoup plus facile à gérer que la
rénovation énergétique des maisons
individuelles et donc j'y viendrai un
petit peu après et je rejoins beaucoup
de constats qui ont été faits par
Florence Liévin mais le premier je
voudrais inciter sur la planification
la planification parce que dispositif
financier les délégataires les acteurs
de la rénovation énergétique son sujet
et sont en attente de l'enveloppe
financière que ce soit pour ma prime
rénov ou pour pour laisser deux œufs et
nous souhaiterions qu'il y ait une
planification plus réelle pour connaître
l'ensemble des budgets qui pourront être
alloués à cette rénovation énergétique
planification pourquoi parce que la
première des choses c'est que la filière
doit se structurer et pour structurer se
structurer pardon elle a besoin de
visibilité dans le temps aujourd'hui on
le sait les fraudes sont également liés
à des effets d'opportunités
d'opportunisme il se trouve qu'avec une
certaine planification ça serait une
certaine barrière à l'entrée pour des
acteurs qui voudraient se lancer dans
les chantiers de rénovation ou sur ce
sur ce type de marché et d'ailleurs on
l'a vu on a on identifie on voit des
sociétés qui se lancent de la rénovation
énergétique et qui avance était lancée
dans le
de formation dans des business des
masques on le voit
beaucoup beaucoup aujourd'hui donc je
pense que la planification serait très
intéressante d'avoir à deux trois ans
quatre ans les budgets de l'État
notamment sur sur MPR et ça ça serait
vraiment très important pour rassurer et
structurer la filière des artisans à
l'accompagnement jusqu'à
l'accompagnement des prises en main des
logements la deuxième c'est
l'anticipation l'anticipation
législative réglementaire et en Florence
l'évoquait tout à l'heure mais c'est
très important on a de temps en temps on
doit s'adapter c'est une de nos forces
les entreprises délégataires ou qui
accompagnent la rénovation énergétique
on sait de faculté à s'adapter ont des
équipes qui s'occupent du réglementaire
mais on ne peut pas être
on ne peut pas devoir s'adapter du jour
pour le lendemain ça nous permet pas et
d'un être efficace et de deux de remplir
les missions qui nous sont données
la troisième c'est la lisibilité la
lisibilité des dispositifs aujourd'hui
on confond accompagnement social
accompagnement à l'efficacité
énergétique MPR peut s'occuper de faire
sortir des logements de passoire
thermique mais également s'occuper
d'efficacité énergétique les c2eux qui à
la base étaient un dispositif spécifique
pour l'efficacité énergétique s'occupe
maintenant un peu de précarité donc on
parle de ces deux oeufs précarité et
aujourd'hui cela manque de lisibilité
pour
identifier et bien comprendre quels sont
les missions de chacun et je pense que
ma prime rénove ce dispositif public
devrait principalement s'attaquer au
fait de sortir des logements du statut
de password thermique et vraiment cette
attaquer à cette cette problématique
sociale et sociétale très forte et donc
la lisibilité pour moi est extrêmement
importante la quatrième chose c'est
l'efficacité
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'argent est mis
sur la table pour rénover les logements
individuels et on a on manque d'outils
de mesure
compétent qui nous permettent de
comprendre et de voir où est-ce qui est
allé notamment l'argent public comment
est-ce que l'on mesure les économies
d'énergie réelle poste chantier c'est
une vraie problématique sur lequel est
Lio on souhaite vraiment s'attaquer et
rendre visible ce sujet parce que on
doit mesurer c'est pas possible que dans
deux trois quatre ans on se rend compte
que les rénovations énergétiques qui ont
été faites n'ont pas été efficaces et
donc on doit mettre à notre avis des
outils de mesure pertinents même dans le
diffus et il se trouve que ça fonctionne
dans les copropriétés ça fonctionne dans
le tertiaire ça fonctionne c'est plus
c'est plus simple il y a des acteurs qui
sont entre guillemets plus structurés
mais on voit que c'est efficace et la
cinquième chose c'est la responsabilité
et ça me fait ça me permet de faire le
lien avec le dispositif mon
accompagnateur rénove mais aujourd'hui
on a mis
une chaîne supplémentaire dans le
dispositif c'est très important mars
c'est très bien on doit accompagner les
gens on doit les sortir les aider dans
leur démarche mais en revanche le marre
ne va pas porter la responsabilité des
économies d'énergie réelle et personne
dans la chaîne de valeur ne porte cette
économie d'énergie réelle donc c'est à
dire que on va se lancer dans une
rénovation énergétique
MPR on va dire on va rénover 700 000
logements par an mais le résultat quel
est le résultat final quelles sont les
économies d'énergie réelle qui porte
cette responsabilité des économies
réelles et de la réussite des chantiers
et des travaux donc là il y a une vraie
question une question fondamentale de
qui est-ce qui porte cette
responsabilité de la réussite de cette
rénovation énergétique au-delà de la
quantité et du quantitatif mais du
qualitatif et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui doit à mon avis être porté à
votre connaissance et en même temps un
sujet et un chantier fondamental pour ne
pas que l'on se réveille dans 5 10 ans à
se dire ben voilà énormément d'argent
ont été mobilisés mis sur la table mais
qu'est-ce qu'il en est ce qu'on doit
recommencer dans dans 5-10 ans donc
voilà un petit peu le constat et ce que
l'on peut dire sur les
l'avis de Lio merci
bonjour à tous et merci beaucoup pour
l'invitation et merci pour l'initiative
salutaire de cette commission d'enquête
quelques mots sur hifi donc et si on est
une entreprise de 300 personnes
également concentrées sur le residentiel
l'accompagnement des particuliers on
intervient à peu près auprès de 100000
familles par an donc on est on est
aujourd'hui un des leaders sur
l'accompagnement de la rénovation
énergétique on le fait à travers grâce à
nos 3600 partenaires partout en France
et on accompagne les particuliers pour
la plupart des travaux de A à Z c'est à
dire que on va faire mûrir leurs projets
les accompagner pour mobiliser les aides
les certificats d'économie d'énergie ma
prime rénove pour les accompagner dans
du financement sur le reste à charge
également sur la réalisation des travaux
et sur le contrôle de ces travaux
alors je voudrais juste apporter un peu
de solennité parce que vous nous avez
effectivement demandé de juré donc il y
a beaucoup de sérénités et voilà je
pense que ce qu'on va ce qu'on va avoir
à discuter ici les décisions que vous
allez avoir à prendre
elles pourront faire date elles pourront
faire date parce que vous allez avoir un
choix à l'issue des auditions sur est-ce
que aujourd'hui au point où on en est
sur le système de dispositifs d'aide à
la rénovation énergétique et plus
largement des politiques publiques celui
de laisser faire des entreprises
véreuses qui contournent et qui abusent
du système et qui floue des milliers de
ménages ou est-ce que vous allez faire
le choix d'enfin encadrer efficacement
pour avoir des systèmes vertueux au
profit des citoyens et de la
collectivité et donc c'est un choix qui
va qui va engager collectivement toute
la société sur la rénovation énergétique
alors vous l'aurez compris moi je vais
concentrer mon propos liminaire sur les
principaux freins à la rénovation
énergétique qui sont pour nous la
méfiance des particuliers et le
dysfonctionnement des aides du fait des
abus qui qui auxquelles elles font face
alors d'abord un constat positif sur le
disposition les dispositifs d'aide elles
ont permis de mettre en mouvement des
filières on a parlé vous avez reçu
Olivier David juste avant qui vous a
donné des chiffres moi je vais vous en
donner aussi quelques-uns sur les
certificats d'économie d'énergie en
trois ans entre 2019 et 2021 on a eu 700
000 chaudière remplacées on a plus de 2
millions d'isolations réalisées qui ont
bénéficié des certificats d'économie
d'énergie on a chaque année maintenant
depuis 2020 des centaines de milliers de
travaux qui sont réalisés avec ma prime
rénov pour autant la question reste
entière c'est quoi le bon calibrage de
toutes ces aides et en fait on voit
qu'on ne signe systématiquement entre
quand elles sont trop faibles et ben
elles sont pas suffisamment institatives
et finalement on déclenchent pas les
travaux chez les particuliers et quand
elles sont trop généreuses voire trop
incitatives ça marche trop bien et donc
ça coûte trop cher
ou alors ça attire des écoles
délinquants et alors on les arrête et
donc la conclusion c'est que aujourd'hui
on sait pas piloter la politique
publique de la rénovation énergétique
autrement qu'avec des stops and Go et
donc on distribue aujourd'hui des
milliards
tu as parlé de 6 milliards sur les C2E
mais si on cumule effectivement tous les
dispositifs on arrive facilement à 10
milliards d'euros on distribue des
milliards via un dispositif qu'on ne
s'est ni piloter ni contre les finement
c'est ça le constat aujourd'hui qu'on
fait nous acteurs de la rénovation
énergétique alors ça date pas de ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui ça date de il y a un
petit bout de temps avant-hier
on parlait du solaire des abus sur le
crédit d'impôt on a mis des moratoires
en 2010 sur le solaire c'était des
crédits d'impôts hier le démarchage
téléphonique vous en parliez et nous on
a beaucoup œuvré pour interdire le
démarchage téléphonique donc 2020
interdiction du démarchage téléphonique
arnaque sur l'isolation des combles en
euros on pourrait revenir puisque EFI
avait été
les commentaires du dispositif des
combles 1 € donc on pourra revenir si
vous voulez mais les arnaques des
combles 1 € sur les certificats
d'économie d'énergie et puis aujourd'hui
vous l'avez vous avez auditionné
quelques acteurs les arnaques sont ma
prime rénove les arnaques sur le coup de
pouce rénovation globale on pourra en
parler donc on s'aperçoit que le
phénomène n'est pas récent le phénomène
il a plus de 10 ans et si on continue à
l'ignorer dans le meilleur des cas c'est
que l'on est trop naïf et dans le pire
des cas c'est quand même qu'on sait
dangereux et donc on pourrait rentrer
dans chacune chacune de ces aides et
faire le détail de ce qui va et ce qui
va pas dans chacune de ces aides mais la
réalité c'est que les abus ne sont pas
liés au dispositif
ils ne sont pas liés à la typologie de
travaux mais ils sont simplement liés au
manque d'ambition qu'on sait donner pour
piloter et contrôler ses politiques et
c'est très important de d'entendre ça
parce que chacun va vous dire non mais
les certificats d'économie d'énergie non
mais ma prime rénove non ça a été
valable Action Logement ça a été valable
sur l'ensemble des dispositifs de
rénovation énergétique et donc nous on a
passé d'alerter depuis les filles qui
existent depuis 15 ans mais un minimum
moi depuis que je suis là et même avant
depuis 10 ans tu es dispositifs existent
on n'a pas cessé d'alerter sur le
démarchage sur le 1 euro quand il a été
ouvert à tout le monde alors que avant
c'était un programme sur lequel est
fille avait un monopole aujourd'hui
encore sur la rénovation globale sur les
détournements qui sont faits sur la
rénovation globale et donc en fait on
nous a systématiquement opposé soit la
complexité trop grand nombre d'acteurs
puisque c'est des acteurs différents qui
distribuaient différentes aides soit le
manque de moyens et c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui pour nous c'était important
de faire des propositions d'ailleurs on
vous en a envoyé on vous en envoyer et
les et les étoffer mais c'est important
d'avoir des propositions à la fois sur
le renforcement de la coordination
interministérielle pour un meilleur
pilotage des aides leur distribution de
leur accompagnement et surtout des
boucles de rétroaction quand on pense
une aide pensez à la façon dont on va la
piloter et on va la contrôler donc ça ça
suppose de rapprocher et de renforcer
les équipes dans les différents
ministères écologiques
et évidemment Bercy les différentes
agences et les évidemment les organismes
de qualification mettre en place une
taxe force interministérielle qui a
vraiment les pouvoirs d'agir et de
piloter ces politiques et puis ce qu'on
demande c'est une véritable police de la
rénovation énergétique avec une ambition
budgétaire à la hauteur des enjeux et
donc c'est pas forcément un budget
important
ce qu'on dit c'est que il suffirait
peut-être de aujourd'hui on disait 10
milliards d'euros si on cumule
l'ensemble des aides il suffirait
d'avoir 1% pour appeler ça le 1%
contrôle 1% dédié au contrôle des
actions et des milliards qu'on met sur
la table pour les politiques de
rénovation énergétique
donc
pour conclure pour pas être longue le
président monsieur le rapporteur on
pourra revenir sur d'autres propositions
pourra revenir sur mon accompagnateur
Renov parce que on pense que ça ne
risque pas c'est pas dans le bon sens
pour autant on pense pas que ça va
enrayer le fléau
mais on voulait vraiment porter votre
attention sur le fait que aujourd'hui
il faut absolument mettre un terme à ces
assez a finalement se laisser faire
parce que sinon c'est finalement une
complicité qu'on engage auprès de ces
entreprises véreuses je vous remercie
vous voulez intervenir monsieur non
alors on passe à do ré mi
bonjour à tous donc je prends le relais
avec un une positionnement un petit peu
différent do ré mi n'accompagne pas de
ménage on est accompagnateur d'artisans
de notre côté donc doremie est une
entreprise de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui travaille depuis une
douzaine d'années maintenant en 2011 sur
la mise en place de rénovation
performante on va revenir sur le terme
performant je pense qu'il y a il y a un
sujet entre ce qu'on appelle rénovation
énergétique et rénovation performante ou
se joue beaucoup de choses de calage du
curseur et important je reviendrai là
dessus do ré mi a fait
œuvre de de pionniers en quelque sorte
il y a une douzaine d'années en
structurant des formations sur chantier
pour les artisans
et on s'est rendu compte que c'était
majeur pour faire travailler entre eux
des corps de métiers qui ne se parlaient
pas et pour faire pour avoir réellement
une baisse des consommations
énergétiques de façon très pratique il
faut que des corps de métiers se parlent
il faut que les menuisiers par le
plaquiste il faut que il parle également
au chauffage au ventiliste à celui qui
isole la toiture et donc tout ce monde
là doit se parler donc ça ça a été notre
premier travail on s'est rendu compte
ensuite que avoir des très très bons
artisans c'est bien mais si on n'est pas
dans une logique de confiance côté
ménage ça suffisait pas donc on a
travaillé à l'accompagnement des ménages
on ne le fait pas en direct
volontairement pour pas mélanger les
genres par contre on forme des
accompagnateurs au niveau local donc ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui de service
public côté mon accompagnateur Renov on
a été formateur dans ce cadre là et on
l'est toujours aujourd'hui
et ensuite on s'est rendu compte que il
fallait accompagner les ménages beaucoup
plus
fortement sur les aides vous avez parlé
le président de Maki DZ en introduction
c'est complètement ce qu'on vit depuis
12 ans ça a pas énormément changé depuis
12 ans pour tout dire vu du ménage et
j'insiste parce que c'est ça qui est
important pour la prise de décision
c'est se mettre à la place du ménage vu
du ménage les aides restent extrêmement
complexes et dans tout notre enjeu c'est
de simplifier ça donc on a créé des
outils pour simplifier l'approche du
ménage tout simplement et faire en sorte
que le ménage puisse beaucoup plus
facilement accéder aux aides ça reste
encore extrêmement complexe extrêmement
laborieux donc on pourra revenir sur ce
point là qui est très important aussi
dernier point quand on a
tous cette chaîne
d'accompagnement
au choix des travaux d'accompagnement
mécanicien et les bons artisans ça
suffit pas il y a un dernier point qui
reste à contrôler c'est que ce qui est
fait sur le chantier c'est bien ce qu'on
cherche et donc de l'autre côté on parle
de suivi qualité on parle pas de
contrôle aujourd'hui mais on est en
faveur d'aventure en puissance le
contrôle et du suivi qualité qu'est-ce
que c'est que le suivi qualité c'est
s'assurer que ce qui était prévu au
démarrage c'est bien là au final et
qu'on rend au ménage finalement une
maison un outil maison finalement qui
réellement performant donc voilà le
positionnement on va dire de do ré mi
dans le dans le paysage je voudrais
juste faire quelques retours
d'expérience en
quelques mots
de notre côté notre positionnement est
basé sur la rénovation performante et
principalement la rénovation globale
alors je vous renvoie à la définition du
du débats
il y a eu beaucoup de débats la
définition est probablement pas parfaite
elle est quand même extrêmement
intéressante en gros une rénovation
performante permet au ménage d'avoir un
logement de classe A ou B
C si c'est une passoire énergétique et
on a évidemment des dérogations pardon
pour le évidemment mais on a beaucoup
dérogations derrière mais globalement
réno-performantes c'est A ou B év
éventuellement C si on part d'une
passoire énergétique rénovation globale
c'est atteindre ce niveau là de
performance en une fois en gros en moins
de 18 mois
ce qui nous
[Musique]
ce qu'on constate concrètement ce qui
nous frappe quand on travaille au
quotidien sur les chantiers avec les
artisans avec les ménages c'est que en
mettant en place ce type d'approche on
arrive sur des divisions par 4 à 10 et
consommation de chauffage donc nous
c'est notre pratique quotidienne c'est
de diviser par 4 à 10 les consommations
de chauffage des ménages
avec des tous les mécanismes que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure rapidement ça ça
veut dire que on arrive en allant
chercher les bonnes aides et en
réduisant fortement les consommations à
faire un modèle économique pour le
ménage donc ça c'est un élément
important aujourd'hui on est sur des
rénovations qui coûtent 70 80 90 000
euros
il faut se le dire c'est pas c'est pas
40 ou 50 000 euros comme on avait avant
le covid ça a augmenté fortement et donc
on a des montants très très élevés par
contre ces montants là on arrive à s'en
sortir si on cale bien la politique
publique des aides et si on a des bonnes
rénovations avec évidemment
l'effondrement de la facture de
chauffage donc tout le travail de la
politique publique pour nous doit être
de bien caler le curseur et de caler le
curseur pour le bon niveau de
performance le premier constat qu'on
fait c'est que le
les mécanismes financiers de l'État
qui s'appelle ma prime rénovénoglobale
ou coup de pouce rénovation performante
aujourd'hui ils font référence à des
niveaux de consommation qui sont pas
ceux de la loi
on est à 35% d'économie d'énergie dans
un cas 50% dans l'autre et c'est pas du
tout cohérent avec les classes A B ou
éventuellement C de la définition du
Code de la Construction donc là pour
perdre les ménages les artisans et tous
les acteurs de l'accompagnement il y a
déjà
enfin pour éviter de les perdre plus
exactement il faut déjà simplifier ça et
faire en sorte que quand on dit qu'on
finance la réno-performante les critères
soient les critères de du Code de la
Construction ça c'est extrêmement
important et aujourd'hui on la passe
voilà donc ça c'est un premier élément
côté simplification des aides moi
j'insisterai sur ce point là très très
spécifiquement qui est qui rendrait
beaucoup plus lisible les différents
points sur l'harmonisation des des aides
il y a plusieurs choses qui ont été
dites j'insisterai simplement sur le
fait que aujourd'hui quand vous êtes un
ménage vous avez le choix entre
énormément d'aide vous avez le choix
entre des enfin aussi de mobiliser des
prêts éco-préat taux zéro je voudrais
juste insister un tout petit peu là
dessus les coopératos 0 aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et extrêmement difficile à
mobiliser si vous êtes un ménage modeste
j'oublie les très modeste parce qu'ils
n'ont pas accès aujourd'hui globalement
si vous êtes aménage modeste vous
pourrez y avoir accès mais c'est
extrêmement complexe et si vous êtes
aménager aisé ou intermédiaire vous irez
accès au bout de plusieurs mois de
négociation donc il y a un problème
au-delà de la subvention
il y a un problème de mobilisation des
acteurs dans quelle mesure la politique
publique peut davantage
inciter les acteurs bancaires à aller
vers cette approche ou plus
donc ça c'est un point clé il faut
arriver à travailler sur la modélisation
des aides pas seulement bloc par bloc ma
prime rénov d'un côté C2E de l'autre et
qu'au prête au zéro il faut une
continuité vue du ménage il faut que ce
soit un seul mécanisme en fait c'est
vraiment extrêmement important d'avoir
ce positionnement là et je crois que les
ce qui est en train d'être travaillé
côté gouvernement actuellement
pour le projet de loi de finances 2024
porte sur l'évolution de nouveau de ma
prime rénov et pas de l'ensemble des
éléments donc pour pour rendre plus
efficace ou plus efficient la politique
publique il faut aller vers cette
logique de lisibilité vu du ménage bon
ça c'est sur la partie aide il me semble
que c'est important le deuxième point
sur l'accompagnement ce que l'on
constate c'est que
l'accompagnement aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisamment orienté vers la performance
l'accompagnement aujourd'hui
c'est une réponse aux demandes du ménage
le ménage ne s'est même pas qu'il est
possible de diviser par 4 à 10 c'est
consommation de chauffage
si on n'arrive pas à lui montrer que
c'est possible
et par ailleurs c'est ce qui est marqué
dans le code de l'énergie globalement
l'objectif BBC en moyenne nationale en
si on lui montre pas que l'objectif le
ce qui est désirable ce qui est
intéressant pour lui c'est cette ce
niveau de consommation BBC dans sa
maison et ensuite on l'aide à voir
comment on fait si on n'a pas ce
cheminement là évidemment le ménage il
demande un changement de fenêtre ou un
changement de chaudière et donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve
systématiquement cette approche où on
retombe dans le choix des ménages
changement de chaudière changement de de
fenêtre de menuiserie donc ça pour
sortir de là il faut réussir à faire en
sorte que le référentiel des
accompagnateurs rénove
soit réellement orienté performance on
projette le ménage dans sa maison fini
de rénover ensuite on voit comment on
l'accompagne pour ça ce qui nous
inquiète beaucoup bon on n'a pas
directement été impliqué dans le montage
de de côté mon accompagnateur Renov ce
qui nous inquiète beaucoup c'est de voir
que il y a aucune formation de prévu
aujourd'hui pour les accompagnateurs
Renov il nous semble que c'est un point
un point fondamental
et pour finir sur cette partie
accompagnement il y a un point qui est
fondamental c'est que à partir du moment
où il y a quelque chose à débourser pour
le ménage
débourser quelque chose pour
l'accompagnement avant les travaux en
France extrêmement difficile donc sur
les premières années
de trois ans quatre ans le temps de
lancer la machine il va falloir accepter
de notre point de vue que la politique
publique finance fortement
l'accompagnement des ménages je pense
notamment au modeste est très modeste
pour lequel cet accompagnement là il
doit être pris en charge intégralement
si on veut que ça décolle après au bout
de quelques années de stabilisation là
on peut revoir les curseurs mais au
démarrage on a besoin de cette
positionnement là aujourd'hui c'est
c'est
on n'est pas dans cette logique sur mon
accompagnateur Renov du moins par
rapport aux infos qu'on a aujourd'hui
parce qu'on n'a pas tout et ça ça nous
inquiète beaucoup il y a un troisième
point que je voulais mettre en avant
c'est le choix
de du volume de travaux financé par les
aides
quand on voit que sur les C2E rénovation
énergétique trois quarts même un peu
plus parte sur des pompes à chaleur
on se dit qu'il y a un problème de
positionnement c'est-à-dire que des
certificats d'économie d'énergie ils
doivent pouvoir être utilisés sur des
bouquets de travaux
qui réellement baissent les
consommations en partant du besoin du
ménage c'est-à-dire effondrer la facture
de chauffage et ça c'est pas du tout
pris en compte c'est à dire qu'on fait
dans le désordre des des actions de
travaux je vous renvoie sur un rapport
de l'ADEME de 2021 rénovation
performante par étape qui montre que
changer la chaudière au démarrage c'est
le plus mauvais choix qu'on peut faire
dans une rénovation énergétique donc
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à faire en
sorte que les mécanismes financiers
ainsi que les ménages à faire
de la baisse de conso en isolant ça
c'est un enjeu clé en termes de
positionnement donc les propositions
comporte par rapport à ça c'est c'est
notamment l'usage d'un outil très simple
sur lequel on s'appuie qui est dans le
domaine public qui se base sur des
bouquets de travaux pré-calculés
je vais pas rentrer dans les choses trop
techniques mais ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que les calculs
conventionnels qui sont utilisés dans
les outils DPE audit
aboutissent à une infinité de solutions
qui perdent le ménage les artisans et
peut-être même les accompagnateurs donc
mettre en place un filet de sécurité
avec des bouquets de travaux
pré-calculés
on les met en place depuis 12 ans de
notre côté on a des retours d'expérience
extrêmement positifs de leur
compréhension de l'adhésion des ménages
et des artisans et de leur mise en
oeuvre et ça ça permet finalement qu'un
auditeur un diagnostiqueur puisse très
facilement préconiser des travaux qui
soient lisibles pour tout le monde et
tout l'enjeu derrière c'est de faire en
sorte que les aides puissent s'appuyer
sur ces mêmes bouquets de travaux pour
que dans la continuité on finance au
niveau politique publique ce qui est
préconisé par les diagnostiqueurs les
auditeurs
j'ai un
dernier point que je voulais mettre en
avant sur il y en aurait beaucoup mais
un dernier point que je voulais mettre
en avant sur la partie fraude
notre positionnement de notre côté ça a
été de travailler sur un réseau de
format ce qu'on appelle des formateurs
experts donc identifier sur la centaine
de territoires la centaine de
collectivités locales sur lesquels on
travaille
d'identifier
des bons termitiens que l'on forme pour
être formateur sur chantier et qui
deviennent dans le temps nos contrôleur
finalement donc aujourd'hui on doit en
avoir 70 ou 80 au niveau national pour
nous on peut faire d'une pierre deux
coups en faisant en sorte que la
politique publique travaille à la fois
sur la formation des opérateurs parce
que ça vous n'avez pas mentionné mais je
pense que c'est un des éléments clés de
la politique publique si on veut s'en
sortir côté dynamique il faut qu'on
arrive à former les opérateurs de
travaux et ça c'est un des enjeux de la
politique publique aujourd'hui ni
cancer du travail ni le ministère de la
transition ni de ministère d'éducation
nationale ou de la formation ne se
sentent investis du travail de monter en
compétences des opérateurs de travaux
alors que ça les concerne tous donc
arriver à poser ce cet objectif de de
formation des opérateurs et faire en
sorte que les formateurs qu'on va former
pour ça devienne nous contrôleur au
niveau national pour nous c'est un enjeu
clé on a mis en ligne notre référentiel
de qualité pour que il puisse être
librement copié
l'enjeu pour nous c'est d'arriver à ce
que le suivi qualité qui est réalisé au
niveau des rénovations ce soit des
suivis qualités qui nous permettent
réellement d'aboutir à ce qu'on cherche
le népotique publique c'est à dire de la
rénovation performante voilà j'arrêterai
là je parlais pas de précarité
énergétique et autres il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire encore mais on aura le
temps des questions pour ça merci alors
texial
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
et merci à la Commission de nous donner
l'opportunité de parler de rénovation
énergétique évidemment si un enjeu
majeur alors textial en quelques mots
pour pour donner des éléments de
contexte texial est une société de
services en efficacité énergétique qui
existe depuis plus de 30 ans maintenant
nous sommes 300 collaborateurs nous
réalisons des services sur l'ensemble du
du territoire nous sommes des légataires
de ces deux œufs mandataires de Lana
pour ma prime rénov et membre du gpc2e
qui s'est qui s'est exprimé avant moi
nous accompagnons nos les Français dans
leur projet de rénovation énergétique de
bout en bout en apportant des solutions
à chaque grande étape les quatre grandes
étapes les quatre grands services que
nous que nous proposons c'est d'abord
l'évaluation initiale de la performance
thermique du logement
l'expertise technique sur les sur les
travaux les solutions de financement et
puis le respect de la qualité de la
conformité des travaux des travaux
réalisés
alors pour répondre aux questions de la
Commission et vos questions madame la
Présidente
j'ai j'aimerais mettre en avant trois
enjeux du secteur de la rénovation
énergétique qui me semble être des
enjeux clés pour accélérer encore la le
dispositif
le premier visant à améliorer encore le
dispositif le deuxième
visant à accompagner mieux le dispositif
qui n'est pas suffisant en soi et puis
troisièmement
un enjeu qui vise à compléter le
dispositif de rénovation énergétique
existant alors premier enjeu
je suis convaincu que les que le
dispositif et l'ensemble des acteurs
doivent garantir au ménage des
rénovations qui sont réellement
efficaces
c'est indispensable pour atteindre les
objectifs français et européens et puis
aussi pour redonner la confiance des
ménages pour qu'ils comprennent
ce à quoi ce dont il bénéficie quand ils
font des travaux de rénovation
énergétique évidemment
donc pour pour atteindre cet objectif je
crois qu'il faut intégrer dans le
dispositif progressivement des
obligations de résultats
sur les économies réelles et j'allais
dire réellement mesurer
y compris alors c'est déjà le principe
de la rénovation performante
c'est c'est aussi le principe des des
contrats de performance énergétique dans
le domaine dans le domaine industriel
c'est c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
être étendu au ménage français y compris
pour les opérations monogestes
deuxième
proposition pour pour atteindre cette
objectif
il faut qu'on s'assure que les travaux
réalisés par les Français sont les bons
alors les bons travaux ça veut dire les
Français adaptés les travaux pardon
adaptés à chaque situation et à chaque
logement au besoin de chaque de chaque
logement et je crois que dans ce dans ce
cadre là il faut recourir plus
systématiquement à un audit ou à une
évaluation thermique de chaque logement
des des Français alors qui dit audit dit
audit de qualité évidemment et aussi des
audits qui sont aidés qui sont pas
qui sont pas juste une charge pour les
pour les ménages
et puis dernier
point pour ce premier ce premier enjeu
je crois que c'est je crois qu'il faut
redonner confiance aux Français dans ce
dans ce dans ce dispositif beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été faites par les
pouvoirs publics sur la lutte contre la
contre la fraude il y a ces derniers
mois ces dernières années un gros
renforcement des contrôles à la fois sur
les demandes d'aide et puis sur les et
puis sur les travaux mais je pense qu'on
peut aller plus loin et qu'on peut
renforcer les contrôles des différentes
habilitations des acteurs de la de la
rénovation énergétique et contrôler les
dispositifs de qualification à la fois
en habilitation et en renouvellement de
d'accréditation ou de ou d'habilitation
deuxième
enjeu pour
pour déclencher les trains les travaux
au niveau des au niveau des ménages je
crois qu'il faut une offre
d'accompagnement à la fois clair et
complète alors permettez
rapidement deux chiffres
du baromètre sur la rénovation
énergétique on réalise tous les ans avec
opinion Wayne d'abord 78% des Français
ne sont incapables de citer une offre à
la rénovation énergétique et puis 73%
des français
demandent souhaitent à avoir un guichet
unique et un interlocuteur unique
donc on voit bien qu'il y a un réel
besoin une réelle demande d'un
accompagnement d'un accompagnement de
bout en bout du projet de la de la
rénovation je crois que c'est le rôle
des sociétés de d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique de pouvoir
agréger les différentes étapes les
différents services et de pouvoir
garantir le respect à chacune de ces
étapes de la règle de la réglementation
et puis une offre une offre
d'accompagnement claire ça veut dire ça
a été ça a été dit c'est ça nécessite
une stabilité de l'ensemble du
dispositif à la fois sur les aides et
puis le cadre le cadre réglementaire les
fiches ces deux œufs les aides m'imprime
rénove en particulier devrait pouvoir
être dimensionné
correctement dès le début et permettre
de donner de donner un cadre un cadre en
France aux français qui soit stable avec
un minimum de visibilité
et dernière dernier enjeu qui me semble
qui me semble important et qui vise à
compléter le le dispositif le dispositif
c'est le financement du reste à charge
je crois qu'on dit tous d'accord pour
pour dire que les dispositifs d'aide en
particulier C2E et les aides publiques
comme ma prime rénove ne peuvent pas
tout faire
on peut même dire qu'il ne doivent pas
tout faire parce que les restes à charge
trop faibles
on
crée des situations qui sont extrêmement
fradogènes
pour autant il faut qu'on puisse
financer le reste à charge qui peut être
qui peut être très important dans ces
rates de rendre certaines dans certains
types d'opérations
et force est de constater que les les
dispositifs complémentaires de
financement comme le nouvel éco PTZ où
le prêt avance rénovation
ont du mal à décoller on parle de
quelques centaines de d'opérations
financées depuis le depuis le début de
l'année
donc je sais qu'il y a des discussions
en ce moment entre les pouvoirs publics
et puis les le secteur le secteur
bancaire je pense que on attend on
attend un certain nombre de
décisions
pour pour financer pour compléter ce ce
dispositif de la rénovation énergétique
donc en conclusion pour pour récapituler
trois enjeux majeurs un pour améliorer
encore le le dispositif et le rendre
plus efficace
deuxièmement une offre d'accompagnement
claire et complète tout au long du tout
au long du projet et puis un complément
de financement et une mobilisation
renforcée du financement du reste à
charge
merci donc on va terminer cette première
échange avec symbiote
on commencera par vous après
est un syndicat oui mettez votre micro
symbiote est un syndicat multibrange qui
regroupe les acteurs de la filière avale
c'est-à-dire les installateurs des
industriels des artisans des entreprises
des délégataires des bureaux d'études et
aussi des architectes donc je pense
qu'on peut donner un retour d'expérience
terrain qui est pertinent
je ne reviendrai pas sur ce qui a été
dit mais je pense que l'arrêt des aides
brutales sans délai sans planification a
été vraiment un coup d'arrêt de toute la
filière qui commence à se structurer
pour la rénovation énergétique
nous avions demandé que ça puisse que
l'on puisse basculer des des aides par
gestes vers la rénovation globale si
j'allais dire avec une un délai de un an
pour pouvoir structurer économiquement
la filière malheureusement les aides ont
été arrêtés à le mois d'après nous
sommes afin de vivre la même situation
en ce moment sur le coup de pouce lié à
la rénovation globale ou un projet
d'arrêter prévoit effectivement un
changement de pied dans moins d'un mois
donc nous avons encore écrit qu'il
fallait laisser du temps et que nous ne
revivions pas ce que nous avons vécu
pour l'arrêt des combles à 1 € qui était
peut-être légitime mais pas dans les
délais dans lesquels ça c'est fait
l'instabilité effectivement quasi
permanente
soit des montants d'aide soit des
arrêtés sur les dispositifs de ces deux
œufs est incompréhensible maintenant
pour le public qui est complètement
découragé et aussi pour les entreprises
ça c'est un fait les entreprises ne sont
plus du tout motivées pour les travaux
d'économie d'énergie parce qu'elles ne
savent plus ce qu'elles doivent
transmettre à leurs clients et
elles-mêmes ne comprennent pas si c'est
si important d'aller vers la sobriété
énergétique pourquoi alors que c'est
important ma prime rénove a cesser
toutes les aides à l'isolation pour les
revenus dit supérieures mais qui ne sont
pas quand même des revenus colossaux à
partir de janvier 2023
lorsqu'il y a eu l'arrêt des coups de
pouce à 1 euro dans les comptes pour
laisser deux heures nous avons demandé
que ça puisse être transporté dans ma
prime rénove pour qu'effectivement les
travaux d'isolation continuent d'être
aidés dans la prime rénove nous n'avons
pas été entendu nous en sommes à un
nombre de réunions de lettres
incalculable depuis un an et demi sans
se faire entendre et pour arriver au
point que nous pensons aussi notamment
pour la rénovation globale qu'il faut
une continuité enfin une cohérence une
homogénéité entre ma prime rénov et les
c2o mais nous militons aussi depuis
maintenant plusieurs années pour que ce
que l'on appelle une rénovation
performante globale soit bien celle qui
a été retenue au niveau de du plan
énergie climat celle qui a été retenue
dans la loi dans le Code de la
Construction c'est-à-dire le niveau BBC
c'est-à-dire l'équivalent en classe A ou
B parce qu'aujourd'hui tous les travaux
qui ne sont pas faits à cet objectif là
c'est du gisement d'économie d'énergie
que l'on tue tout simplement et on le
tue pour 20 ou 30 ans donc nous militons
effectivement pour que au niveau des C2E
comme imprime rénove pour les maisons
individuelles particulières puisque les
maisons individuelles sont au nombre à
peu près de 15 millions en France elles
sont particulièrement réparties dans le
milieu rural dans le milieu rural il y a
très très peu de beauté il y a très très
peu d'architectes et vous pouvez pas
faire faire 150 km à l'auditeur pour
aller faire une audition de maison parce
que bien sûr financièrement il est
incapable de pouvoir tenir donc on pense
que des combinatoires de travaux
pré-calculés comme cela a été fait par
l'association passeport rénovation il y
a quatre ans déposés à la dégeln des
projets à la des EC qui ont été validées
et contrôlées sont de nature à permettre
des rénovations globales performantes à
permettre une bonne lisibilité et à
permettre aussi la simplicité
donc là je rejoins parfaitement Vincent
sur ce sujet là et il a été au courant
des travaux complètement plusieurs
années on a on a besoin d'un bon d'une
bonne évaluation technique du bâtiment
mais une entreprise peut le faire les
entreprises savent très bien lorsqu'il y
a une pathologie lorsqu'il y a un toit
qui a des problèmes et savent très bien
faire un diagnostic mais les
combinatoires de travaux et la feuille
de route des travaux d'une maison on
peut l'écrire d'entrée de jeu avec le
DPE et au moins on sait vers quoi on
doit faire les étapes arrêter de faire
effectivement les travaux par étape qui
sont à l'envers aujourd'hui 70% des
primes qui sont données par la NAS sont
donnés uniquement pour des pompes à
chaleur il n'y a plus de travaux
d'isolation or qu'on sait que les
travaux d'isolation réduisent le besoin
en énergie la demande en énergie donc
réduisent la consommation et réduisent
des facto
de façon quasiment définitive sur les 50
ans les consommations d'énergie et les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
c'est la proposition que nous avons fait
nous n'avons porté cette contribution au
8 mars le 8 mars dernier dans le cadre
du Plan 2 de sobriété énergétique et
nous la maintenons nous espérons que
nous finirons pas être apparaître
entendu et nous souhaiterions
effectivement que dans ma prime rénove
comme dans les certificats d'économie
d'énergie on puisse faire une véritable
fiche rénovation globale performante par
bouquet de travaux en moins de 3 étapes
en laissant effectivement avec des
financements qui sont à la hauteur de
l'enjeu puisqu'on sait effectivement
comme la divincent globalement le coût
d'une rénovation globale performante on
est entre 60 000 et 90000 euros en
fonction de la région en fonction des
surfaces mais on sait aussi que en
faisant en moins de trois étapes sur
moins de deux ans c'est supportable
aussi pour les ménages qui habitent
parce que sinon il faut continuer à
pouvoir habituer dans son logement alors
concernant le financement là encore si
je ne sais pas si vous êtes amusé
mesdames et messieurs à aller sur le
site ma prime Réno pour faire vos
calculs de financement et d'aide ces
cornéliens j'étais encore dans mon
village hier et j'ai un particulier qui
est venu me voir parce qu'il sait que je
m'occupe pas mal de l'efficacité
énergétique il en a 20 mois d'attente 20
mois d'attente pour le remboursement
d'aide mais c'est pas fini parce qu'au
bout de 20 mois il a eu un contrôleur
qui est passé un accompagnateur et neuve
qui est passé pour faire le constat des
travaux il l'attendait depuis 6 mois
six mois
et maintenant l'accompagnateur rénove a
mis le dossier sur la plateforme et le
particulier ne s'est toujours pas quand
il sera réglé il ne sait pas quel est le
montant qu'il se pour lequel il sera
réglé en attendant l'entreprise a
avancer l'argent en particulier et
l'entreprise elle a fait de l'avance de
trésorerie et en milieu rural il y a
énormément d'entreprises qui font de
l'avance de trésorerie pour les
particuliers et les particuliers
lorsqu'il reçoivent une aide qui n'est
pas celle qui a été prévue ne peuvent
pas payer l'entreprise
et c'est l'entreprise qui se retrouve à
endosser l'écart de prix donc un on
pense qu'on peut faire effectivement ma
prime rénov il faut lire le guide de la
NAT qui fait 45 pages pour comprendre
effectivement comment on fait des
calculs vous avez des écrêtements par
travaux après vous avez des écrêtements
en fonction des en fonction des
ressources après vous avez un
écracrètement global en fonction de
l'ensemble des travaux plus un
décritement global ces deux œufs plus ma
prime rénov
c'était tout ça pour arriver quand même
un reste à charge pour les couples qui
est aussi entre 16000 euros et 28000
euros
on peut pas s'en sortir on a quatre
classes de revenus on sait très bien que
les trek Packers ne peuvent pas prendre
du reste à charge donc faut trouver un
mécanisme de financement avec une avance
remboursable
peut-être par la caisse des épaules par
la banque des territoires il faut
peut-être monter une structure il avait
été proposé un temps dans le moment où
vous avez la loi de l'environnement du
Grenelle de l'environnement de créer un
établissement public un fond
d'investissement à fond de financement
qui pouvait effectivement faire une
avance remboursable sur les travaux
d'une maison et évidemment l'État se
repayant s'il y a session du bien ou
s'il y a héritage de succession parce
que de toute manière même les revenus
supérieurs qui aujourd'hui sont à 29000
euros par an qui n'est quand même pas
excessif pardonnez-moi ils ne peuvent
pas rembourser un reste à charge à 40
000 euros une avance remboursable oui ou
alors il faut qu'effectivement les
banques commencent à jouer les jeux
décopettais zen on l'a mis le produit
décopéties aides a été mis en place avec
la première loi Grenelle
aujourd'hui on a à moins de 50000
dossiers traités par an et encore jamais
pour la rénovation globale le taux
maximal de le déco PZ la majeure partie
c'est moins de 12 12000 euros vous
pourrez contrôler je me trompe peut-être
à 1000 euros près parce que j'ai pas
pris des chiffres avec moi mais on en
est là donc il y a pas de financement de
la rénovation globale or on sait que le
seul moyen de gagner les objectifs des
missions de Gazette de réduction de gaz
à effet de serre et de réduction des
consommations de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat à long terme pour les ménages de
façon pérenne et structurelle c'est
effectivement d'aller vers des
rénovations globales performantes
c'est à dire effectivement que la vie
Vincent on a des divisions par 6 ou par
4 en moyenne par 4 ou 6 des maisons
quand on est BBC certifié ça existe il y
a des labels on sait le faire en
revanche permettant de permettons de
mettre des dispositifs de contrôle et de
surveillance de fraude d'adéquate
aujourd'hui quand on voit qu'il faut 20
mois plus de 20 mois de traitement d'un
dossier parce qu'on a plusieurs
personnes qui regardent le dossier et
qui compare des signatures entre elles
qui compare des papillons en tête qui
compare des rubriques rjeux qui
comparent des numéros sirènes or qui a
le moyen d'intelligence artificielle par
des systèmes blockchain et de le faire
pourquoi ne mettons pas l'argent où il
faut c'est-à-dire assouplir par des
systèmes blockchain toute la
surveillance entre guillemets ce que
j'appelle administrative et mettre
effectivement l'argent soit pour payer
tous les audits énergétiques et
d'évaluation technique des bâtiments
avant
parce qu'il y a énormément de ménages
qui sont incapables de les payer
d'entrée de jeu ne sachant pas si après
ils pourront faire les travaux ou alors
effectivement mettons cet argent pour
effectivement faire du véritable
contrôle du contrôle correct pas du
contrôle au téléphone en disant
êtes-vous bien madame Michu habitez-vous
bien neuf rue Tartempion non de faire
des vrais contrôles notamment rénovation
globale je pense qu'effectivement il
faut garantir la qualité du travail qui
est fait je ne reviendrai pas sur ce que
Vincent a dit et on a mis l'idée de
nombreuses années ensemble pour pour ce
sujet donc nous je vous ai adressé même
la Présidente je ne sais pas si vous
l'avez eu mais j'ai adressé la
contribution par écrit de symbiote que
nous allons continuer de porter parce
que nous y croyons et alors moi je me
posais une question nous avons un
endroit où ça fonctionne très bien et un
endroit de confiance en France ça
s'appelle la maison France service ça se
trouve dans les mairies
et alors parvenir on s'aperçoit quand
les gens viennent se présenter en mairie
un ils sont accompagnés par des gens du
village ou de l'intercommunalité qu'ils
connaissent ils sont en confiance on a
des gens extrêmement compétents à
mairies pour aider à remplir les
dossiers sur des plateformes donc moi je
ne critique pas du tout les plateformes
mais là ça se fait naturellement et
comme par hasard les entreprises locales
sont connues aussi des mairies
et donc quand il y a une entreprise qui
n'est pas locale ou qui n'est pas dans
le département on va dire on peut quand
même se poser des questions pourquoi ne
pas confier aussi comme aide aux
particuliers le que les maisons France
service puissent aider le particulier à
remplir leur dossier en ligne
vous puissent juger du niveau d'aide et
de conseils dont ils ont besoin parce
que tout le monde n'a pas besoin du
niveau 100% d'aide en revanche il y a
des gens qui sont totalement perdus donc
cela faut les aider d'un bout à l'autre
mais il y a plein de personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément besoin
d'avoir une aide absolue et en même
temps les autres en service c'est un
endroit aussi on peut suivre le dossier
et on a peut-être des chances de savoir
avoir et avoir un calcul précis de
l'aide et quand le dossier est accepté
l'aide ne doit plus bouger
parce qu'aujourd'hui les dossiers sont
acceptés on vous dit l'aide sera de X et
en fait au bout de 20 mois
l'aide n'est pas celle qui était prévue
donc le particulier ne peut pas payer
l'entreprise l'entreprise fait de
l'avance de trésorerie la banque ne suis
plus l'entreprise et l'entreprise mais
la clé sous la porte donc comme ça on a
on a gagné on est allé au niveau zéro du
gagnant-gagnant donc l'idée de regrouper
de faire des primes dans le fil des
travaux oui et moi je pose une question
pourquoi ne pas faire une avance de
prime au niveau des travaux au départ du
chantier
à l'entreprise qualifiée
30% 30% 30% à la fin
ça donnerait peut-être une obligation de
délai de traitement et par des systèmes
blocs chênés en temps réel on arrive
parfaitement à géopoly géolocaliser des
photos à contrôler des papiers en tête à
contrôler des factures on va vers les
factures je crois il me semble il me
semble les facturer électroniques à la
date de juillet 2024 il me semble que la
loi s'applique à ce moment-là
pourquoi elle fait-on pour les factures
pourquoi ne fait-on pas pour
l'instruction des dossiers essayons de
monter un chaînage logique et puis pour
ma prime rénov arrêtons tous les six
mois d'enlever des primes pour
l'efficacité énergétique et la sobriété
c'est à dire pour l'isolation on y
arrivera pas c'est pas en changeant les
ampoules qu'on permet de réduire le
volume habitable
donc on est prêt à participer à toutes
les commissions que vous souhaitez et
être force de proposition je n'irai pas
plus loin je vous remercie madame le
Président et monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup aux autres pour ce tour
d'horizon déjà très complet très
intéressant donc je vais laisser la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
[Musique]
non moi j'avais peut-être des questions
sur
enfin je pense que tout le monde a parlé
en fait de comment comment arriver à
aller justement sur de la rénovation
globale alors après derrière le terme de
rénovation globale on a bien compris
voilà sur la question de BBC etc et
d'aller sur de la véritable rénovation
globale mais en tout cas déjà le constat
qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui c'est que
la plupart des aides effectivement ne
vont pas ils ne sont pas diriger vers
cette rénovation globale et plutôt sur
de la rénovation par geste et avec des
gestes parfois qui peuvent être on va
dire contestables en tout cas sur le sur
le cheminement donc dans cette dans
cette orientation là et donc dans ce
qu'on pourrait mettre en place pour
faire en sorte que l'on soit plus plus
précis enfin il me semble qu'il y a la
question de l'accompagnement vous en
avez tous parlé et de savoir comment en
fait
voilà des personnes qui veulent rénover
leur maison ou leur appartement vers qui
se tournent et comment ils sont
accompagnés et quelles informations ils
peuvent obtenir déjà dans un premier
temps pour se dire
vous avez parlé d'un passeport du
bâtiment ou en tout cas de lui donner
plein de plein de noms qu'on veut mais
en tout cas d'avoir une lisibilité pour
se dire voilà ce que je dois faire et
voilà dans quelle priorité je dois le
faire et de quelle et voilà quels sont
les étapes et c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelque chose moi qui va pas mal
intéressé sur la question des bouquets
de travaux pré-calais
est-ce que ça me semble quelque chose
d'intéressant on est allé
il y a quelques semaines sur sur
Grenoble et donc sur la métropole
grenobloise et notamment pour voir le
dispositif murmure et c'est vrai qu'ils
ont ils ont ce système en fait voilà
avec des bouquets 1 2 et 3 en justement
ne finançant plus du coup de rénovation
par geste mais vraiment s'inscrivant
voilà avec ce système de bouquet et du
coup il y a une étude qui est faite ils
ont cette visibilité globale et puis
après ben en fonction des financements
qui sont obtenus etc ils vont se mettre
sur tel bouquet 1 2 ou 3
mais en tout cas ils savent sur quel
ordre et comment avancer et puis sur les
possibilités de le faire en plusieurs
fois donc ça c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît qui nous a paru en tout cas
intéressant et c'est vrai peut-être en
termes de lisibilité et donc peut-être
déjà avoir une question sur le DPE
quel est votre votre vision enfin en
tout cas bon on sait que c'est quand
même un outil on va dire maintenant qui
est devenu incontournable et sur quel
s'appuie ensemble oui opposable et puis
sur lequel s'appuie l'ensemble et des
politiques publiques c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait aussi penser à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus simple en fait et qui
s'appuie justement sur ces types de sur
ce type de bouquets en tout cas
d'intervention et qui permettrait
d'avoir peut-être plus de lisibilité en
disant voilà comment je peux avancer
dans ce DPE parce que souvent en fait la
confiance ou le manque de confiance
c'est peut-être dans ce cadre-là c'est
que on se fait un DPE on va avoir un
classement et de se dire pour passer de
l'un à l'autre on n'est pas totalement
certain et pas sûr et donc on se lance
pas forcément dans ce
dans ce parcours donc voir si vous aviez
un petit peu des voilà vous votre retour
par rapport par rapport au DPE
ensuite vous avez beaucoup parlé de la
question du contrôle et donc de on va
dire la qualité des réalisations et du
suivi des réalisations
donc là il y a deux aspects c'est vrai
qu'on nous a beaucoup parlé notamment
les organisations professionnelles
et notamment en revenant sur la question
du RGE et de la qualification des
entreprises de se dire que peut-être
qu'on pourrait avoir un contrôle en fin
de chantier peut avoir des contrôles
intermédiaires mais en tout cas en fin
de chantier et un petit peu sur la base
du consuel en électricité et de se dire
en fait est-ce que ça pourrait pas être
un dispositif de ce type là qui permet
quel que soit je dirais la qualification
de l'entreprise d'avoir ce contrôle en
fin de chantier qui permet de
valider de valider les travaux et
ensuite de pouvoir de converser verser
une aide donc ça avoir votre votre avis
par rapport à ça et puis sur
l'accompagnateur sur la compagnateur
Renov c'est vrai que juste avant avant
vous
auditionner la direction générale de
l'énergie et du et du climat et donc on
a pas mal parlé justement de la place de
la compagnateur Renov et c'est vrai que
tel qu'il a été décrit en tout cas c'est
c'est une vraie maîtrise d'oeuvre quoi
et donc plutôt sur des montants qui
iraient entre 1500 et 2000 euros ce
qu'on nous a ce qu'on nous a annoncé en
tout cas sur des prestations et donc
avec un véritable suivi une vraie
maîtrise d'oeuvre c'est vrai qu'on avait
entendu un petit peu tout avec des
prestations qui pouvaient être lors de
150 à 200 euros ce qui est du coup pas
la même chose et qui est pas du tout le
même type d'accompagnement et donc là on
serait plutôt en tout cas tel qu'il a
décrit sur sur Oui de la véritable
véritable maîtrise d'oeuvre se pose
effectivement la question du financement
et du reste à charge parce que ça nous a
aussi été dit que du coup il serait pas
financé intégralement
donc on va avoir votre votre avis en
fait parce que moi il me semblait qu'en
fait bon on va dire que la maîtrise
d'oeuvre en fait existe déjà
des architectes il y a déjà des maîtres
d'oeuvres qui sont qui qui existent mais
qui manque peut-être plutôt quelque
chose d'intermédiaire qui justement
oriente justement sur ces différents
bouquets en fait et qui peut être
peut-être quelque chose de plus de plus
léger et effectivement peut-être
s'appuyer sur ce qui existe d'ailleurs
dans les dans les collectivités à
travers les Alecs les plateformes de
rénovation et donc donner plutôt la main
justement en collectivité et ça va avec
ce que vous disiez sur
sur les maisons France services parce
que je sais que c'est aussi imaginé le
lien entre les maisons France services
et France et France rénov qui peut être
quelque chose effectivement
d'intéressant puisqu'on a une structure
qui existe avec quand même peut-être le
bémol ici au Sénas c'est que maisons
françaises sont peut-être intéressantes
etc mais ça a quand même été un
transfert de charge entre l'État et les
collectivités et les collectivités qui
doivent prendre en charge du coup la
question des services publics donc il y
a quand même cet aspect du du
financement mais en tout cas savoir
voilà votre votre avis aussi sur sur cet
accompagnement en tout cas comment vous
pouvez vous pouvez l'imaginer voilà
alors après vous répartissez réponse
parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas calibré en
fonction de chacun merci
alors qui veut commencer de Rémi oui oui
si ça vous va je veux bien revenir sur
votre première question qui je pense en
fait est structurante sur l'ensemble des
enjeux qu'on a traité la question des
bouquets de travaux prisculés c'était
quelque chose d'assez confidentiel
jusqu'ici à ces techniques
dont on parlait avec certains acteurs
que qu'on a utilisé pour former les
artisans mais qui était encore assez peu
connu et maîtrisé je pense au niveau de
la de la gestion des politiques
publiques et qui apporte pas mal de
réponses nous on le voyait comme un
outil
d'atteinte de la performance c'est à
dire qu'avec un bouquet pré-calculé sur
des simulations thermiques dynamiques en
amont sur une variété de bâtiments on
s'assurait qu'en sortie quelle que soit
la solution choisie parmi celles qui
sont proposées le bâtiment arrivera bien
en classe A ou B donc nous c'était
vraiment une vision de sécurisation de
la performance énergétique des
rénovations
et aujourd'hui cet outil là on le voit
vraiment comme un outil qui peut être
transversal pour répondre à l'ensemble
des enjeux de cette politique sur le
calibrage des aides et les fictions des
fraudes et c'est un retour qui nous a
été fait justement de la semaine
dernière de la DGEC qui voyait cet outil
d'un œil très intéressant sur la gestion
des fraudes quand on pense aujourd'hui
ou au système d'aide qui est calibré sur
l'atteinte d'une étiquette on part de
f.g par exemple pour arriver à aoub on
peut très bien falsifier l'étiquette de
départ l'étiquette d'arrivée pareil les
dispositifs parfois qui sont en
pourcentage d'économies d'énergie on
arrive très bien enfin les auditeurs ou
les diagnostiqueurs peuvent très bien
facifier et il y a eu des retours qui
ont été faits des améliorations bien sûr
pour encadrer les calculs mais on
observe encore énormément de
surestimation des consommations avant
travaux et de sous-estimation des
consommations après travaux et donc
artificiellement
les diagnostiquaires peuvent classer des
logements FG pour avoir des bonus sortis
de passoire et art potentiellement
arriver en Roubaix alors que c'est pas
du tout le cas alors que l'idée
d'utiliser des bouquets de travaux
pré-calculés en complément finalement ça
peut intervenir à différents moments de
la chaîne de valeur au niveau du
diagnostiqueur mais aussi de l'auditeur
puis de tout l'accompagnement et de
l'éligibilité aux aides le fait de dire
qu'une aide est possible pour un ménage
si latin une étiquette mais aussi avec
le filet de sécurité d'avoir traité les
les différents éléments du bouquet de
travaux ça permet de sécuriser c'est à
dire qu'on pourra pas tricher sur le
fait de dire que la maison arrive en
aoubet si on n'a pas fait une partie de
l'isolation ou une partie de la
ventilation qui est prévue dans le
bouquet de travaux ou pareil le fait de
de combiner ces éléments là sécurisent
vraiment le l'efficacité de la politique
de rénovation et ça c'est assez majeur
dans le sens où aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il y a énormément d'argent public qui
est mis sur les DPE et les audits nous
ce qu'on voit c'est que depuis des
années on arrive à faire des rénaux BBC
sans faire d'audit et qu'avec des
bouquets pré-calculés on a une économie
public qui est majeur aujourd'hui
maintenant on est obligé de passer par
des audits pour de nombreuses aides donc
on les fait quand même mais c'est pas du
tout eux qui guident vers les bons les
bons bouquets de travaux très souvent
les préconisations des audits et des DPE
tombent à côté de la performance et
c'est bien ça le problème donc
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est pas
forcément évident dans le paysage des
aides actuelles vous les audites et les
DPE ont pris un rôle majeur de faire
table rase de tout ça par contre c'est
possible assez facilement et assez
rapidement de former les diagnostiqueurs
et les auditeurs et les accompagnateurs
rénov à ces bouquets de travaux en
disant on remet pas complètement en
question le système de calcul si vous
voulez faire des calculs faites les
calculs mais faites en sorte que les
préconisations qui ressortent soient
également valides au regard des bouquets
de travaux et là on évite des Lamont
énormément de fraude
ça facilite aussi un deuxième échelon
qui est celui du suivi des du chantier
et des contrôles on vous parliez si on
sait qu'elle bouquet travaux on a choisi
on sera exactement quel point de
contrôle on ira voir et je pense que
c'est intéressant de le faire déjà
pendant le chantier et pas uniquement à
la fin nous c'est ce qu'on fait on fait
des tests d'étanchéité à l'air
intermédiaire avant les finitions c'est
à dire avant qu'on pose les placos et
les et les enduits par exemple pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les artisans
fassent des corrections et c'est ça
aussi l'enjeu d'avoir un contrôle qui
est qui est pas sanction qui a un rôle
de sanction mais qui a aussi un rôle
pédagogique de monter en compétences de
la filière le fait de le faire en
intermédiaire pour permettre aux
artisans d'identifier avec le contrôleur
quels sont les points à améliorer et
ensuite de permettre du coup au ménage
de pouvoir bénéficier des améliorations
fait qu'à la fin la rénovation sera plus
performante donc finalement on a un
outil qui est vraiment ce que vous
disiez ce qui est utilisé par murmure
par exemple il y a différents types de
bouquets il faudra rentrer dans le
détail des bouquets qui peuvent vraiment
simplifier à énormément d'endroits et
fiabiliser surtout ce qu'on observe
oui je voudrais juste compléter pour
qu'on se comprenne bien quand on parle
de bouquet de travaux les combinatoires
qui ont été calculés ce sont des
combinatoires de performance
combinatoire de performance de parois de
performance de système de chauffage de
production de choses sanitaires de
performance étanchéité à l'air des
logements et c'est ça qu'on appelle les
combinatoires donc c'est bien une
performance et on retrouve cette
performance dans l'étiquetage des
produits ou dans leur normalisation ou
dans leur certification donc c'est en
cela que quand on quand on fait des
bouquets avec des parcours de travaux
typiquement si on sait qu'on va avoir
une étape fatale qui va être la toiture
on commence par la toiture c'est pas un
problème peut-être qu'il y a un problème
au niveau des planchers ça n'est pas non
plus grave de commencer par les
planchers mais on fait des parcours qui
font qui soit toutes les parois
et on a sorti les équipements au fil
typiquement si on isole il faut ventiler
si on fait les isolations des murs on
fait aussi l'isolation des fenêtres et
on met la ventilation donc il y a des
couples ou des couples binômes ou
trinôme ou par 4 deux postes trois
postes ou 4 postes et dans ces postes-là
les combinatoires pré-calculés de
travaux en fonction des zones
climatiques ont été faites elles ont été
remises je suis content de savoir que la
dégesse c'est maintenant les approuve
parce qu'il y a 5 ans c'était pas tout à
fait le cas et en fait je pense que ce
serait bien dans ma prime rénov comme
dans les
la fiche C2E sur la rénovation globale
doter la valeur limite de 330 kWh
d'énergie primaire parce qu'aujourd'hui
on dit une rénovation performante c'est
une réversion qui est en dessous de 330
kWh d'énergie primaire par mètre carré
c'est à dire en dessous de la Classe E
n'est-ce pas
c'est à dire que et on dit 330 kWh parce
que c'est le niveau minimum de la loi
qui dit que à partir de telle date on ne
pourra plus louer de logements ou de
plus plus mauvais que 330 mais 330 kWh
c'est la classe E donc quand on fait une
fiche rénovation globale où on met une
limite qui est la limite de la Classe E
le signal n'est pas très positif quand
même et après on vous dit il faut avoir
gagné 35% de d'économie d'énergie mais
si on parle de 700 kWh
on arrive jamais qu'à une classe entre D
et E à la fin c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
la bordure de donc en fait militons et
nous militons pour que la fiche
rénovation globale performante puisse
comporter plusieurs niveaux n'ayons pas
peur un niveau à l'étiquette classique
et pour certains bâtiments des fois on a
du mal à les emmener plus loin qu'une
classe C
et un deuxième niveau classe B ou
équivalent a et il donne la possibilité
soit de faire des calculs pourquoi pas
avec la méthode 3cl ou une autre méthode
de manière elles sont toutes
conventionnelle donc il y a pas de
problème ou d'appliquer des
combinatoires de travaux mais si déjà
dans un arrêté action standardisée on
mettait les niveaux de performance en
kilowatt-heure qu'on attendait avec les
moyens atteints différentes avec des
combinatoires
on sait ce qu'on va contrôler en fait ça
devient pédagogique et faisons un
copier-coller dans ma prime rénoble
aujourd'hui les indicateurs les critères
pour ma prime rénov en rénovation
globale ne sont pas les mêmes que pour
les C2E c'est la quadrature du cercle
pour tout le monde donc essayons de
simplifier et je pense qu'effectivement
le fait de publier
réglementairement des combinatoires
pré-calculées avec les niveaux de
performance et quand même de nature à
aider la pédagogie et à permettre aux
entreprises de savoir aussi elle elles
sont pas idiotes si elles savent
qu'elles n'auront une subvention que
pour du 4 du 5
elles vont voir leur négoce elle demande
du CAP ou 5 c'est savent que le coq de
la pompe à chaleur il doit être 4,5 et
encore moyen elles vont le demander les
entreprises en France on a des
entreprises du bâtiment qui ne sont pas
des voyous et après qu'elles soient RGE
ou simplement cannibales comme
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de retard
de 2 ans de retraitement de traitement
de retard dans le RGE
les entreprises qu'on leur qualification
canibates n'attendons pas qu'ils aient
leur jeu ils ont mis la clé sous la
porte dans deux ans alors et en revanche
après faisons des contrôles
effectivement pertinents
donc je pense que ce serait une bonne
façon et puis des audits je voudrais
simplement rappeler quand vous avez posé
la question de la compagnateur Renov
j'ai fait un tout petit calcul pour 500
000 logements rénovés par an même si on
commençait par 300 000 on serait modeste
en fait je voudrais simplement vous dire
que la maîtrise d'oeuvre il faudrait
plus de 50 000
mètres doivent supplémentaires
et qu'avant qu'on arrive à les former
et avant qu'on arrive à les installer
dans les campagnes il va y avoir
énormément d'eau qui va couler sous les
ponts alors il vaut peut-être mieux
essayer de trouver un autre moyen je ne
suis pas contre la maîtrise au contraire
le problème c'est d'arriver dans les en
ville ça se passerait bien en zone
suburbaine ça se passe très bien mais
vous êtes à 1h des grandes des grandes
villes vous n'arrivez plus à en avoir
donc je pense qu'il faut trouver un
autre moyen et l'accompagnateur rénove
y compris les gens qui sont jolis dans
les à la disposition des agences anales
locales il manque il manque 50 000
personnes
si on veut faire 500 000 logements par
an je crois qu'on peut en faire 700 000
j'ai cru comprendre donc il faut trouver
un autre moyen des combinatoires de
travaux avec une feuille de route
dressée au départ la feuille de roue de
la teinte de la classe A c'est ça ça
dans tel ordre et on fait des
combinatoires et ça c'est un peu le
surveiller
on peut on peut le surveiller avec une
feuille de route qui soit effectivement
fiable alors sur la méthode des pe3l
elle est pas plus mauvaise que l'autre
alors il y a les filles ensuite Elio et
puis bien sûr alors
sur la première question rénovation
globale versus rénovation par gestes
vieux débat
je veux pas mettre un pavé dans la marre
mais en fait cette opposition
systématique entre les deux nous on la
comprend pas et on pense qu'elle est
dangereuse que d'avoir un discours que
lorsque la rénovation n'est pas globale
elle n'est pas performante pourquoi
parce que quand on a réalisé des
isolations des combles perdus chez les
ménages ménage très modeste à l'époque
du 1 euro qu'on pourra dont on pour
pouvoir parler
faire c'est le plus efficace au départ
après il faudrait effectivement faire
l'isolation de thé sol et puis des
fenêtres et puis tes murs et puis et
puis la totalité de ton enveloppe et
après changer ton système de chauffage
aujourd'hui il y a rien dans la
réglementation et dans les aides telles
qu'elles sont définies qui amènent à ce
parcours cohérent donc aujourd'hui soit
vous avez des aides pour du monolo et
principalement de la bonne du changement
de système de chauffage donc
effectivement la pompe à chaleur parce
qu'on est dans des réflexions de
massification et ce qui est le plus
simple aujourd'hui à massifier pour des
réflexions à la fois climatiques et à la
fois énergétique c'est la pompe à
chaleur et on est dans ah bah sinon on
peut donner un paquet assez important
d'enveloppes budgétaire accompagné dans
la logique de la rénovation globale mais
en fait entre les deux il y a rien et
donc quelqu'un qui se dit en fait moi je
veux monter les marches une à une
et finalement mais dans le bon ordre
évidemment d'abord son isolation ensuite
l'isolation de séquence de ces murs
ensuite sa pompe à chaleur
éventuellement ensuite la VMC quand ces
éléments là sont bien mis dans l'ordre
la rénovation peut être performante mais
vous allez pas
vous dire qu'à un moment donné les gens
vont se réveiller un matin et se dire je
vais faire de la rénovation globale donc
il y a des moments évidemment qu'il faut
capter et ça on a beaucoup de mal à les
capter qui sont les mutations les mises
en location les vraiment les moments de
la transaction c'est le meilleur moment
pour proposer la rénovation globale
pourquoi pour deux raisons la première
c'est que ces moments là en général on
peut faire un prêt on peut faire du
déficit foncier on a des dispositifs
dans lesquels on a dû financement
première élément deuxième élément c'est
des moments en général on n'habite pas
le le bien donc on va réduire les
désagréments ce sont les moments idéaux
il y a 800 000 transactions de vente en
France chaque année 800 000 on pourrait
cibler spécifiquement alors ça a été
ciblé dans le cadre notamment la mise en
location avec l'interdiction de location
des passoires thermiques il y a la
transaction de la vente avec l'audit
obligatoire on commence à aller vers ça
mais il y a vraiment un enjeu à pouvoir
cibler ces moments de vie mais vraiment
enfin
c'est compliqué pour un particulier et
nous on le voit tous les jours avec les
gens qu'on a au téléphone un jour vous
leur dites il faut il faut absolument
mettre du gaz le lendemain vous leur
dire non en fait c'est l'électricité
faut faire de la rénovation par geste et
de la pompe à Shanna ah non en fait ce
qui est vraiment performant c'est la
rénovation globale les gens sont perdus
donc je pense qu'il faut arrêter avec
des des choses qui sont trop binaires
trop dogmatiques la réalité c'est qu'il
faut qu'il y ait de la complémentarité
nous chez les filles on accompagne des
gens sur la rénovation globale ça prend
plus de temps on en fait beaucoup moins
on accompagne une cinquantaine de
personnes aujourd'hui de famille sur la
rénovation globale et on fait aussi on
propose des gestes et on essaye
fortement d'inciter les gens à le faire
dans le bon ordre voilà donc c'est
vraiment c'était un point que je voulais
je voulais souligner sur les contrôles
donc effectivement nous ce qu'on a vu
dans la dérive de ces dernières années
c'est que on a privatisé les contrôles
aujourd'hui les contrôles dans certains
dispositifs et notamment dans les
certificats d'économie d'énergie ils
sont privatisés c'est à dire c'est les
entreprises privées qui dirigeantes des
bureaux de contrôle et qui financent les
contrôles donc ils financent des
contrôles pour se contrôler eux-mêmes
donc ils sont à la fois jugés partis et
donc il y a une dérive sur les contrôles
parce que vous avez interrogé des
bureaux de contrôle vous avez fait deux
heures sur la fraude donc je vais pas
renouveler le discours vous l'avez
entendu mais on est aujourd'hui dans une
logique de privatisation des contrôles
il faut revenir à une réflexion sur
comment on re nationalise les contrôles
quelque part et que on redonne la main à
la puissance publique pour assurer le
contrôle ça suppose du budget c'est ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais
effectivement le fait de d'avoir une
réflexion autour d'un équivalent consuel
en tout cas d'un opérateur de contrôle
diligenté par les pouvoirs publics et
d'en faire beaucoup plus et sur site
évidemment c'est pas appelé les
particuliers pour vérifier s'ils
existent bien et s'ils ont effectivement
fait des travaux c'est se rendre sur
site parce que c'est les contrôles sur
site qui vérifieront de la qualité des
travaux c'est essentiel sur mon
accompagnateur Renov
alors c'est c'est nous on a été beaucoup
associé aux travaux de de Monsieur
Seychelles et après dans le cadre de mon
accompagnateur Renov
ça va dans le bon sens il y a une
question de périmètre le périmètre qui a
été choisi dans un premier temps c'est
mon accompagnateur rénove obligatoire
dans le cadre de la rénovation globale
pour les ménages modestes et très
modeste dès lors que 35% de performance
cet accompagnement il est nécessaire
parce que ces personnes sont les plus
vulnérables ce sont celles qui sont les
plus sujettes aux échos de Lacan dont je
parlais tout à l'heure la réalité c'est
que ça existait quand même des gens
m'imprime rénove sérénité Lana sérénité
c'était bien de l'accompagnement par des
opérateurs de Lana pour ce type de
ménage donc cet accompagnement il va
dans le bon sens ensuite il y a deux
autres types de périmètre il y a le
premier périmètre qui est les ménages
aux revenus intermédiaires et aux
revenus pour de la rénovation globale
peut-être qu'on peut se dire que pour
ces pour ces ménages là on n'a pas
forcément besoin d'avoir le même type
d'accompagnement que pour des ménages
modestes et très modestes pour faire ce
type de travaux et donc là aujourd'hui
la loi prévoit que pour ces ménages là
mon accompagnateur rénov ne soit pas
obligatoire et puis on a
une deuxième étape dans mon
accompagnateur Renov qui à partir de
septembre d'imposer mon accompagnateur
Renov dès lors que on sollicite 10000
euros il m'a prime rénov de manière
simultanée ou quand on réalise plusieurs
travaux dans moins de 3 ans ça c'est un
c'est une c'est une condition et une
obligation qui a été imposée et qui en
réalité complexifie énormément le
parcours du particulier pourquoi le
particulier il va se lancer il va faire
une isolation de ses murs par
l'extérieur
il va avoir il va solliciter un montant
d'aide qui va être de l'ordre de on va
dire 100 m², 75 euros du mètre carré de
l'ordre de 7500 8000 euros et puis -3
ans après donc là il l'a fait sans mon
accompagnateur Renov c'était un geste
c'était moins de 10000 euros et puis
moins de 3 ans après et ben il va
solliciter des aides pour obtenir une
pompe à chaleur ce qu'il a fait les
choses dans le bon ordre on l'a bien
conseillé et puis il va solliciter une
fac maintenant ce cas là on va devoir le
conditionner le cette deuxième année au
parcours de mon accompagnateur de rénov
et c'est quoi le parcours de mon
accompagnateur c'est un accompagnateur
Renov un audit un contrôle de cette
audit la réalisation de ces travaux le
contrôle post travaux on rentre dans un
système qui complexifie fortement il
faut savoir aujourd'hui le premier frein
des particuliers c'est la complexité si
vous leur dites aujourd'hui vous avez
finalement vos deux travaux vous allez
les faire à chaque fois finalement un ou
deux mois et dans le deuxième temps vous
leur dites ben non en fait tu dois
passer par mon accompagnateur rénov et
là on va rajouter 3 4 - 5 mois pour
fluidifier toute la chaîne parce que
c'est pas du tout les mêmes
interlocuteurs mon accompagnateur Renov
ne doit pas être celui qui exécute les
ouvrages donc on doit être dans une
logique très distincte donc on va on va
complexifier là où on a voulu massifier
donc dans la massification il y a des
dérives on en a parlé tout à l'heure il
faut absolument les contrôler et mettre
les moyens pour autant attention à ne
pas rendre beaucoup plus complexe ce qui
est déjà pour le particulier
alors Elio
je partage pas mal de choses qui ont été
dites mais la première des choses vous
parlez tout à l'heure de mutation des
biens et je pense qu'il y a un acteur
qu'on a un peu oublié dans la chaîne de
valeur c'est le notaire le notaire
aujourd'hui il a une connaissance très
fine des particuliers qui l'accompagnent
des ménages qu'il suit depuis des années
et je pense qu'il a un rôle assez
crucial et assez fondamental au moins
dans la validation et dans le stockage
des documents vous parliez de blockchain
tout à l'heure mais la profession
notariale a déjà et met en place une
blockchain notariale pour le suivi des
dossiers des particuliers et pourquoi
pas étendre et accorder une place au
notaire de France qui sont officiers
publics assermentés qui ont une autorité
et en tout cas cette légitimité pour
porter et pour aider et accompagner la
rénovation énergétique la deuxième chose
sur les contrôles c'est que il y a
énormément de contrôle qui sont réalisés
à posteriori des chantiers mais les
délégataires par exemple les ces deux
œufs on est extrêmement soumis au
contrôle mais je pense qu'il faudrait
l'étendre au diagnostiqueur aux
auditeurs et que les filières
professionnels comme kalibat et autres
puissent diligenter des contrôles sur
leur propre filière de manière à
superviser et à encadrer ses
professionnels pour éviter les dérives
comme on en a parlé tout à l'heure la
deuxième chose sur les suivis des
réalisations j'en reviens au point que
j'évoquais dans mon propos liminaire
c'est que on a besoin d'outils de calcul
et de suivi des consommations pour
s'assurer qu'il y ait des une véritable
rénovation globale et performante donc
ça c'est pour moi un des outils que l'on
doit mettre en place le suivi des
consommations dans les logements et puis
la troisième chose sur mon
accompagnateur rénov
ma crainte c'est que il y ait un surcoût
financier et ça on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure si on le multiplie par 300 500
700 000 rénovations par an c'est que mon
accompagnateur est neuve il doit être en
même temps expert financier expert
social psychologue
il doit comprendre en fait et rentrer
dans l'intimité des ménages et c'est
extrêmement compliqué et aujourd'hui on
va devoir former comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure 50 000 personnes comment
est-ce qu'on va le faire on va mettre de
l'argent sur la table et à la fin qui
est-ce qui va porter la responsabilité
j'en parlais tout à l'heure la
responsabilité des économies réelles
d'énergie le monde accompagnateur est
neuf c'est pas lui vers qui le ménage va
pouvoir se retourner pour dire mais
écoutez non le chantier a mal été
réalisé ou en tout cas les économies
d'énergie qui étaient attendus ne sont
pas au rendez-vous
donc je me pose la question quelle est
la meilleure personne qui pourra porter
cette responsabilité de l'efficacité de
ces chantiers
alors on va prêcher un petit peu pour
notre paroisse mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que les entreprises qui
accompagnent qui sont des services
financiers et qui connaissent l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur engage leur
responsabilité financière leur
responsabilité sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui toutes les entreprises et
filles nous et Lio d'autres ont des avis
des avis vérifiés sur Google on a on
joue carte sur table on a l'opinion qui
nous regarde qui peut nous noter qu'à un
moment donné si on préconise des choses
on se doit de les assumer et si ça
fonctionne pas on se fait taper dessus
on se prend des pénalités financières on
assume cette responsabilité et quand on
s'engage c'est aussi le rôle des
entreprises de dire voilà si on s'engage
et qu'on réalise ce que l'on veut on est
payé pour notre service et pour notre
travail donc je pense que effectivement
un encadrement est nécessaire un
encadrement des contrôles très fins je
dirais peut-être pas jusqu'à une police
de la rénovation énergétique même si il
faut aller sur des contrôles très
stricts et très précis mais en tout cas
je pense qu'il on a besoin de faire
confiance aux entreprises du privé pour
pour la rénovation énergétique on a
besoin d'être considéré aujourd'hui on
sent que les délégataires des gataires
C2E pour être labellisés Marc on sent
qu'on n'a pas forcément qu'on nous dit
oui vous pouvez peut-être y aller mais
ça va être compliqué on sent qu'il y a
pas forcément une volonté de nous
accompagner dans le la créditation et la
volonté d'être labellisément donc là
c'est vraiment
suivez n'ayez pas peur de du privé et
qu'on travaille ensemble effectivement
plus il y aura une altérité un partage
de connaissances et un partage de
données plus je pense qu'on avancera
dans dans le bon sens merci beaucoup oui
je vais rester sur ce sujet de mon
accompagnateur Renov on y est forcément
extrêmement favorable les Français ne
font pas des travaux de rénovation
énergétique tous les jours une fois
peut-être deux fois dans leur vie
majoritairement le message que voudrait
faire passer c'est attention à ne pas
être déceptif par rapport à cela et ça
rejoint les propos tenus par mes
collègues juste avant des sceptif parce
que sur le terrain on ne trouverait pas
l'accompagnateur rénov pour pouvoir
lancer son projet desceptif parce que
finalement on aurait l'accompagnateur
mais les délais dans lesquels ils
pourraient intervenir ou derrière les
entreprises qui seraient à même de
réaliser les travaux elle-même ne serait
pas disponible ou si on reprend le cas
cité tout à l'heure on aurait l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur qui est présente
mais les délais de versement de la prime
ne serait pas au rendez-vous donc c'est
vrai on va pas parler d'effet d'annonce
mais attention toutefois vis-à-vis des
Français à ne pas faire miroiter à
partir du 1er septembre un dispositif
dont on n'aurait pas forcément cerné
toutes les conséquences y compris
psychologiques que ça on va derrière sur
les Français on a parlé pas mal des
offres un euro même si on n'est pas
revenu dessus on a encore pas mal de
particuliers sur le terrain qui nous
disent mais moi je ne me lancerai pas
dans les travaux parce que j'attends le
retour des offres à un euro c'est vrai
que ça a marqué profondément les esprits
il faut pas refait c'est pas qu'il faut
pas refaire cette erreur mais là on est
en train de dire on va vous accompagner
de A à Z et ça c'est aussi extrêmement
bien et quelque part ça va créer une
rupture puisque on va arrêter de dire et
de faire croire aux Français que une
fois que les travaux de rénovation sont
réalisés ça y est c'est fini non en fait
quand les travaux de rénovation sont
réalisés c'est presque le début de la
nouvelle histoire et ce qui est très
intéressant à l'accompagnateur rénov
c'est toute la partie d'accompagnement
justement derrière et tous ces gestes y
compris de sobriété je suis pas sûr
qu'on en est beaucoup parlé pour le
moment dans cette commission en tout cas
autour de cette table ronde qui vont
pouvoir en découler voilà donc prenons
bien la mesure et puis si nous nous
rendons compte que finalement on n'a pas
l'ensemble des petits bâtons qui sont en
rendez-vous peut-être honnêtement se
poser la question du report sommes-nous
prêts on est à quelques mois de du
lancement on n'a pas encore les
informations vous le disiez vous-même
sur le coût de la prestation et où sur
le coup du soutien comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour des acteurs notamment
des acteurs économiques qui voudraient
se positionner sur le sujet pour
construire derrière un modèle et une
offre adaptée sans avoir ces
informations et rapidement sur d'autres
points monsieur le rapporteur sur le DPE
et plus largement au l'audit pour nous
c'est le point crucial en fait c'est
celui de l'état des lieux et clairement
si on n'a pas la bonne photographie de
la situation initiale et comme l'ont dit
mes collègues dans la mesure où en tout
cas sur les C2E c'est ce qui va
conditionner ensuite le montant et la
délivrance de l'aide il est
malheureusement assez facile de tricher
en effet sur le sujet donc plusieurs
pistes soit il faut arrêter de
conditionner les aides aux résultats des
audits/depe ça c'est une première chose
ou alors il faut aller vers beaucoup
plus de contrôle en effet sur ce qui est
mentionné ensuite il reste tout de même
aussi une més information très
importante sur ce DPE et combien de
ménages nous avons encore qui me disent
mais je ne comprends pas ce DPE ne
correspond pas à ma consommation
énergétique enfin ne faisons pas porter
non plus au DPE qui représentent la
consommation conventionnelle du logement
ce qu'il n'est pas et quand pendant
qu'on parle des outils le dernier point
on n'a pas parlé du tout de carnet
d'informations du logement c'est un
outil c'est un outil fondamental crucial
qui est rentré en application cette
année
de vous à moi je n'ai pas l'impression
que on en parle énormément je ne suis
pas persuadée que les Français et même
juste entendu parler alors que alors
peut-être dans le cadre de parcours de
travaux de combinatoire et autres ce
serait véritablement l'outil sur lequel
appuyer mais alors peut-être pas dans la
forme telle qu'on l'a actuellement il y
avait eu des ambitions au travers de la
loi par rapport à ce carnet bon on les a
perdus en cours de route ça tombe bien
il y a une nouvelle loi de programmation
énergétique climat qui va arriver je ne
sais pas dans quelle mesure vous serez
possible de rehausser ses ambitions mais
ça rejoint la question de la traçabilité
enfin il y a un moment il faut qu'on ait
un suivi y compris pour le parti
particulier le ménage on a un bel outil
qui nous a été proposé par contre il
faut aller au bout de la démarche et le
bout c'est en tout cas d'aller aussi
vers la digitalisation et ça rejoindra
et ce sera ma dernière phrase la
question des contrôles de la blockchain
de la digitalisation à ce jour un
chantier de rénovation énergétique il
peut être contrôlé cinq fois le même
chantier au titre du RGE au titre de ces
deux œufs au type de MPR par le pnc2e
dans le cadre des C2E et si on a mis une
pompe à chaleur hybride par exemple par
Habitat plus
on va venir cinq fois sur un même
chantier comme sur d'autres chantiers on
va jamais y aller on avait posé la
question aux entités concernées par ces
cinq contrôles en disant mais à un
moment est-ce qu'il est quand même pas
possible de rationaliser ça et
d'imaginer une basse commune pour que on
fasse au lieu de faire 5 fois le même
contrôle même j'exagère c'est pas tout à
fait le même champ d'intervention mais
qu'on fasse cinq contrôles sur 5
chantiers différents une réponse nos
systèmes informatiques ne sont pas
compatibles
merci
alors taxi
pour pour répondre globalement sur le
sur l'accompagnement ce qu'on a ce que
je rappelais dans les propos liminaires
c'est que l'accompagnement c'est un
besoin réel et c'est sans doute le le
facteur clé d'une d'une accélération
c'est un métier qui est relativement
nouveau en fait alors je suis pas en
train de dire qu'il faut l'inventer
parce que
mes confrères et concerts
l'exerce depuis depuis un moment mais
quelque part il est quand même encore à
structurer
et c'est un métier pour répondre à cette
attente des des Français c'est un métier
qui est assez qui est complet et qui
agrège plusieurs briques plusieurs
briques de services et l'engagement et
comme le rappelait mon mon confrère
l'engagement
de qualité de satisfaction client de
respect de la réglementation c'est c'est
déjà quelque chose pense que des
sociétés comme nous de
d'accompagnement à la rénovation
énergétique quelque chose que nous
portons des déjà alors évidemment il
faut il faut encore renforcer les
garanties de de ces de ces respects de
réglementation et le cadre réglementaire
il existe déjà pour la plupart des
briques de services de cet
accompagnement il y a un cadre qui est
très strict pour le l'obtention du
statut de délicataire pour les les
audits il y a la qualification au pqbi
pour les organismes de contrôle et
d'inspection
la certification la création COFRAC
pardon donc il y a déjà un cadre qui est
très stricte et pour revenir à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure en introduction je
pense que pour aller encore plus dans le
dans le sens du rassurer les Français il
faut renforcer les contrôles de ces
qualifications à la soit à l'entrée à
l'obtention
des différentes habilitations et puis
aussi des renouvellements puisque c'est
le cas aussi pour les labilitations rgge
il y a des audits et des contrôles de
renouvellement dont la fréquence se
salonge
en mesure que les années passent donc on
peut imaginer des contrôles plus
fréquents et puis on peut aussi imaginer
des sanctions plus importantes si ces
différents acteurs ne respectent pas le
cadre de le cadre réglementaire
donc je pense que c'est c'est célébrant
de structuration de ce métier qui est
relativement récent d'accompagnateurs à
la rénovation énergétique est une clé de
de la confiance de la confiance des
Français pardon et puis peut-être pour
pour préciser sur mon accompagnateur
rénov et puis le DPE et l'audit c'est
effectivement des des briques de cet
accompagnement le dit et le DPE je suis
convaincu que c'est quand même le point
d'entrée à une bonne rénovation
énergétique alors ça peut être avec
différentes méthodes évidemment
et encore une fois ces professions sont
sont extrêmement réglement réglementés
encore faut-il qu'on s'assure que ces
réglementations soient correctement
respectées
alors Franck manteau j'ai une question
ou plusieurs questions je ne sais pas
Franck on va t'écouter
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
tous pour vos présentations vous avez
pratiquement tous évoqué dans vos
interventions la notion d'efficacité si
ce n'est déficience en matière de
rénovation énergétique je voudrais
savoir si chacun dans vos entreprises
vous prenez des vous avez pris
l'habitude ou mis en place des des
dispositifs
d'engagement auprès de vos de vos
clients
est-ce que par exemple voilà vos
prestations sont un des indexées ou
indexés sur des la performance finale
voilà est-ce que est-ce que ça fait
partie de votre de votre de votre
approche ma question générale c'est quel
est votre approche éventuelle ou votre
vision de ce que pourrait être un
engagement de performance réparti entre
tous les acteurs du processus de la
rénovation énergétique il a été question
de blockchain je suis au Sénat de ce
qu'elle a parlé le premier il y a bien
longtemps
et donc je voudrais en marge de la
question principale là que je viens de
poser vous demandez si effectivement
vous avez connaissance de cas ou dans le
cadre d'une de l'utilisation d'une
blockchain on va du début à la fin quoi
voilà on trace absolument tout avec au
bout du compte une mesure de performance
et encore une fois la possibilité
peut-être à partir de ce genre d'outils
voilà que les que les et des autres sont
indexées sur la performance finale voilà
voilà qu'elle était ma question un peu
particulière oui
je veux bien répondre sur cette partie
là parce que ça fait une dizaine
d'années qu'on travaille sur des
logiques de rénovation performantes et
qu'on suit du coup les consommations
il y a un rapport qui est sorti il y a
un an maintenant définir j dans le cadre
d'un projet de recherche ADEME sur des
suivis de consommation de rénovation
qu'on a pu faire et qui permet de voir
où on en est côté côté consommation et
qui montre qu'on arrive aux
consommations qui sont prévues au
démarrage je voulais juste attirer
l'attention sur un point c'est que il
faut faire attention au type de bâtiment
dont on parle quand vous parlez de grand
tertiaire ou de maison individuelle vous
ne pourrez pas avoir une politique
publique ou un suivi des performances ou
un engagement performance de même nature
entre ces deux parcs bâti ça c'est un
point sur lequel j'aurais insister un
tout petit peu au niveau de la politique
publique un engagement
enfin les outils de politique publique
pour la maison individuelle
ou pour le grand collectif ou pour grand
tertiaire en fait il faut il faut
dissocier les approches de politique
publique je vous renvoie un rapport qui
est sorti il y a quelques mois donc de
l'ADEME financement de la rénovation
performante des logements
aujourd'hui dans la politique publique
on n'a pas assez de différenciation
entre les parcs et je vais vous répondre
simplement pour le parc des maisons
individuelles qui est quand même le parc
le plus consommateur au niveau français
10% de la consommation française passe
dans le chauffage des maisons
des maisons d'avance 75 donc des maisons
les plus les plus consommatrices donc
c'est vraiment un gouffre énergétique
ces maisons là sur ces maisons on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui
s'engager au même niveau en terme de
contrat de performance au même niveau
que sur le tertiaire
tout simplement parce qu'il y a des
ménages dedans qui ont des des pratiques
de consommation qui sont très
différentes par contre ce qu'on sait
faire et c'est ce qu'on fait côté de
remise c'est ce qu'on a choisi de faire
c'est que l'outil maison qui est livré
au ménage à la fin des travaux celui-là
on sait avoir un engagement mais c'est
il faut différencier le la consommation
qui réelle après travaux qui est lié au
ménage des travaux que vous avez
effectués je comprends tout à fait la
façon dont on utilise après la maison
l'occurrence
un impact sur le sur la performance
globale
donc vous prenez des engagements de
performance c'est ça ma question voilà
est-ce qu'il y a des engagements de
performance aujourd'hui à votre niveau
comme comme pour d'autres acteurs du
processus global de rénovation
énergétique c'est ça ma question si et
est-ce que donc publié vraiment ça vous
paraît
une voix de progrès
intéressante je vais vous répondre en
maison individuelle un de nouveau
exiger dans les deux trois ans qui
viennent
des niveaux de performance en maison
individuelle avec la sociologie qu'on a
en termes de d'entreprises artisanales
c'est la garantie de ne plus avoir
d'entreprise qui fassent de la
rénovation l'enjeu dans les deux trois
ans qui viennent c'est un enjeu
pédagogique ces données confiance aux
entreprises artisanales au 550 000
entreprises artisanales qui pour 98%
moins de 20 salariés donc ils n'ont pas
d'outils de recherche et développement
ils n'ont pas d'outils de suivi qualité
ils n'ont pas d'outil de formation
ces entreprises là qui sont le tissu
artisanal français il faut arriver à les
accompagner ces entreprises à prendre
confiance qu'ils arrivent à faire de la
performance et ils y arrivent on sait
les faire parler entre eux donc tout
l'enjeu c'est un enjeu de nouveau de
formation et d'un enjeu pédagogique qui
est un qui relève de la politique
publique j'insiste là dessus parce que
c'est aujourd'hui c'est un je vais dire
de toute façon triviale c'est un trou
dans la raquette de la politique
publique il faut travailler là dessus et
on peut travailler là-dessus dans une
logique pédagogique c'est pour ça que je
parle pas de contrôle mais de suivi
qualité on peut montrer aux artisans là
où ils ont bien fait là ils ont pas bien
fait et aller dans les premières années
sur des logiques de fonds de
mutualisation qui font que les ménages
qui se retrouvent avec une maison un
tout petit peu moins performante on sait
compenser ça je vous renvoie un rapport
qu'on a rédigé avec deux loits il y a
trois il y a deux ans maintenant qui est
sorti en novembre 2021 qui propose qui
formule les propositions en termes
assurantielle notamment sur les fonds à
créer pour pour cette atteinte de
performance et par rapport à la
blockchain j'aurais juste insister sur
un point c'est que c'est un outil
extrêmement précieux pour cranter ce qui
a été fait ou pas fait dans les travaux
pour une maison donnée pour un logement
donné ce qui reste à faire et ce qui a
été mis en attente finalement pour la
suite
par contre ça ne fait pas les travaux et
tant qu'on n'aura pas travaillé sur la
pardon pour le c'est très trivial mais
non mais c'est extrêmement important
mais la priorité aujourd'hui c'est les
gens qui travaillent sur le terrain
d'arriver à les accompagner pour qu'ils
sachent faire aujourd'hui les règles de
on n'a pas de règle de l'art pour la
performance aujourd'hui
une entreprise ne sont pas
engagés d'un point de vue réglementaire
par rapport à la performance parce que
ce n'est pas intégré dans les règles de
l'art si on attend 15 ans c'est la
moyenne pour intégrer la performance
dans les règles de l'art on va perdre
l'essentiel de nos de nos engagements et
alors je finis dernier point mais en
rapport vraiment avait ce que vous venez
de dire à l'instant est-ce qu'il serait
envisageable de faire évoluer le RGE
c'est ça
dans ce sens là
alors pas de manière d'emblée
obligatoire avec des exigences voilà qui
qui poseraient problème effectivement
qui ferait qu'on perdrait des
entreprises des artisans etc mais de
manière
optionnelle graduée graduel pour que
voilà hier un mouvement je dirais
général
vers le une véritable
performance de l'ensemble des acteurs et
en particulier des intervenants des
intervenants
je vais peut-être laisser répondre mes
collègues sur cette partie là moi je
considère que ce sera pas forcément
cette approche qui va permettre de
monter en puissance par contre le fait
que les aides soient liés à des suivis
qualité et que c'est suivi qualité
conduisent à avoir des experts sur le
terrain qui épaules ou qui critiquent ce
qui a été fait ça ça va nous permettre
de faire monter en puissance la filière
donc c'est plutôt une logique
d'accompagnement terra plus que de en
fait côté rjeeux la difficulté c'est que
c'est vu comme une formation des
dossiers administratifs ce qui pour 550
000 entreprises artisanales de moins de
20 salariés sont sont des contraintes
donc ça c'est extrêmement difficile
alors du coup je voudrais juste faire un
tout petit pas de côté sur la partie
responsabilité pour finir la réponse et
répondre aussi
aux questionnements de Monsieur Montard
sur la partie maîtrise d'oeuvre vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre une maîtrise d'oeuvre c'est la
loi c'est la loi MOP c'est la loi sur
les marchés publics une un maître
d'oeuvre est une personne physique ou
morale responsable du chantier
responsable du chantier en termes
réglementaire aujourd'hui
il n'existe pas de maîtrise d'oeuf
performance parce que la performance
n'est pas dans les règles de l'art donc
un mètre d'oeuvre si il y a des trous
partout dans la maison en termes
énergétique en termes énergétique pas
des trous en termes d'étanchéité à l'eau
etc mais si au niveau énergétique on
n'atteint pas un certain objectif
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
problématique pour le maître d'oeuvre
c'est pas un engagement
du moins il y a pas grand chose je sais
que vous êtes architectes par ailleurs
donc c'est je fais attention à ce que je
dis mais il y a en fait il y a un
engagement de performance qui est
extrêmement minimal par rapport à la
logique réglementaire donc à mettre deux
il va faire très attention à beaucoup de
choses réglementaires mais la
performance ça va pas passer en premier
quand on regarde ce qui est positionné
au niveau mon accompagnateur et neuve
aujourd'hui non je sais pas ce qui a été
dit avant avec le lit David mais c'est
certainement pas de la maîtrise d'oeuvre
c'est certainement pas de la maîtrise
œuvre parce que un accompagnateur rénov
il est assistant à mettre à mettre
d'ouvrage il assiste le propriétaire du
logement mais mais certainement pas il
prend la responsabilité des
préconisations même le terme
préconisations n'est pas utilisé par
Lana volontairement donc aujourd'hui une
maîtrise d'oeuvre ça nécessite des
assurances
c'est un coût élevé c'est une
responsabilité extrêmement élevée et
globalement je vous renvoie une étude de
la région date un peu de la région
Alsace à l'époque 2015-2016 le coût
moyen en rénovation globale d'un
maîtrise d'oeuvre c'est 9350 euros
9350 euros le prix moyen d'une maîtrise
up et je dirais c'est normal parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de responsabilités là sur
un accompagnateur rénov on parle il y a
des chiffres qui circulent de 1000 1500
2000 euros nous enréno global on sait
pas comment on peut accompagner un
ménage en Réno global en dessous de 2000
à 2500 euros
hors maîtrise devant là je parle de
juste du conseil au ménage on est entre
2 et 3000 euros par contre accompagné en
mon accompagnateur Renov quelqu'un qui
veut juste faire l'isolation des combles
ou juste par une pompe à chaleur
1500 euros ça peut être bien payé donc
je questionne simplement l'objectif
final si on veut accompagner à la Réno
globale 1000 ou 1500 euros
jamais on arrivera à ça aujourd'hui on
forme des agences locales de l'énergie
du climat on forme des opérateurs Ana
Solia etc Il nous disent vous vous
demandez de d'aller vers la Renault
globale avec ce ménage il faudrait 4
heures ou 4h30 de travail pour le
montage financier nous on est payé une
heure et demie comment on fait et donc
on aboutit pas au renoglobal parce que
ils n'ont pas la possibilité de passer
le temps qu'il faut pour les montages
financiers donc là-dessus je serais
vraiment extrêmement prudent et pour
finir la réponse sur cette partie marre
attention aux positionnement qui serait
de faire porter toute une partie du
financement par les collectivités
locales
parce que ce choix là au démarrage je
parle pas en rythme de croisière mais au
démarrage si on éclate encore les
financements comme c'est très
régulièrement le cas on va se retrouver
avec des collectivités qui financent et
d'autres pas et avec une complexité vue
du ménage qui avait qui va être encore
terrible donc on a on met des milliards
d'euros pour faire des travaux
aujourd'hui sans accompagnement sans
contrôle ou avec peu d'accompagnement et
pas de contrôle quasiment du moins des
travaux il y a un enjeu majeur
aujourd'hui à ce que une part
significative de ce financement là dans
les deux trois ans qui viennent soit mis
sur l'accompagnement des ménages avec
des gens formés au niveau de
l'accompagnement au niveau des
opérateurs de travaux donc là j'insiste
vraiment là dessus parce que c'est
structurant
je viens vous lui dire des choses aussi
sur la mutation mais je crois que j'ai
écrit en temps de parole
maintenant on va essayer de voilà de
vous faire encore tous réagir une fois
rapidement pour répondre à votre
question monsieur Montauger non il y a
pas d'engagement de performance alors je
connais pas particulièrement les
pratiques de des 16 membres du GPC 2e
mais globalement pourquoi est-ce qu'il y
a pas d'engagement on pourrait dire
parce qu'il y a pas de demande peut-être
à l'autre bout mais aussi par
construction par construction même des
aides MPR c'est un forfait c'est pas
calculé de base sur les kilowatt-heure
économisés et concernant les C2E c'est
calculer ok sur des kilowatt-heure
économisés mais c'est des kilowatt-heure
théoriques on ne va pas aller regarder
quels sont les économies réelles à la
fin donc finalement je vais pas dire
qu'on a pas d'intérêt à aller sur de
l'engagement de la performance mais dans
tous les cas qu'est-ce que ça va amener
de plus en tout cas pour le ménage ça ne
va rien changer au niveau des aides et
donc la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est de se dire si on veut aller vers
cet engagement de performance ne faut-il
pas conditionner tout ou partie de la
délivrance des aides à la teinte de ses
performances et de ses résultats mais
tant qu'on sera sur de la délivrance au
forfait et sans contrôle des économies
réalisées derrière
quelque part je me permets de vous
retourner la question quel intérêt
aurons-nous à aller sur de la de la
performance et j'arrête être un peu
ironique par rapport à ça la je pense
qu'on est quand même sur un début de
rupture par rapport avec questionnement
et devrait être annoncé d'ici quelques
jours la sortie d'un appel à projet
France 2030 portée par l'ADEME qui
s'appelle opérateur en sanglier et dans
le cadre de la mise en place de ces
opérateurs en sangliers qui seront a
priori des acteurs privés qui viendront
prendre la responsabilité sur l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur de la rénovation
énergétique là oui il y aura une
obligation d'aller vers la performance
pourquoi parce que l'opérateur en semble
y est fait l'avance de l'ensemble du
coup des travaux et vient se rémunérer
derrière sur l'économie réalisée sur la
facture donc c'est le fameux principe du
contrat de performance énergétique que
l'on a démocratisé dans les bâtiments
tertiaires qu'on connaît encore très peu
dans le dans le résidentiel un petit peu
en collectif mais en tout cas pas du
tout vraiment à la marge en maison
individuelle et ça on est à priori
suivant la dame on est à l'aube de
quelques jours de la publication de
cette AP et donc on sait y compris dans
cette salle que des acteurs vont
s'engager pour aller tester ce nouveau
modèle donc oui les choses vont évoluer
mais il faudra quand même quelques
années et ce sera intéressant de faire
un bilan un retour d'expérience de ce
que vont donner ces opérateurs ensemble
qui voulait réagir juste rebondir sur ce
qui vient d'être proposé
méfions-nous quand même des contrats de
performances énergétiques parce que dans
le tertiaire il consiste essentiellement
à se repayer sur les économies faites
dans une dans une valeur qui intéresse
l'efficacité des équipements mais
absolument pas les travaux d'isolation
des enveloppes le paiement d'abord les
CPE portent d'abord sur 10% d'économies
d'énergie sur les régulations et les
réglages des installations et jamais sur
les travaux de des travaux d'enveloppe
alors aller là-dessus dans les maisons
individuelles ça n'a absolument pas la
peine puisque 70% des aides aujourd'hui
sont uniquement pour des pompes à
chaleur dans la maison individuelle donc
privons nous quand même d'un système
enfin d'une approche systémique qui va
être vraiment la Lali de la rénovation
globale dans les maisons individuelles
on y est déjà de toute manière donc
c'est pas la peine on n'a pas besoin de
contraintes performance énergétique pour
installer les pompes à chaleur qui ne
fonctionne pas en revanche la question
de monsieur était très intéressante sur
la garantie de résultats en fait la
performance énergétique finale dépend
des interfaces du traitement des
interfaces des métiers
et en France il y a des réglementations
qui sont très bien faites pour les
logements neufs et pour les logements
existants mais on les applique pas au
niveau des aides à savoir que la mesure
d'étanchéité a l'air d'un bâtiment à la
fin des travaux est un très très bon
juge de paix pour savoir si le menuisier
le plaquiste l'électricien ou bien
travailler ensemble et plutôt que de
donner 1500 euros pour une maîtrise
d'oeuvre qui n'existera jamais puisque
de toute manière il y a pas de maître
d'oeuvre en campagne au front plutôt une
aide de faire une mesure d'étanchéité à
l'air des maisons individuelles une fois
les travaux réalisés je peux vous
assurer que quand les entreprises savent
qu'il y a une mesure d'étanchéité à
l'air à la fin des travaux le respect de
tous les DTU qui sont concernés par les
menuiseries et façades
36.5 les études doublage 25-41 etc ils
sont tous scrupuleusement respectés et
vous trouvez de très très bonnes valeurs
de résultats quand il n'y a pas
l'annonce d'une mesure d'étanchéité à
l'air au stade intermédiaire à la fin
des travaux vous n'y arrivez jamais donc
ça c'est vraiment comment
regarder ce qui concourt à la
performance énergétique finale des
travaux qui sont réalisés donc ça ça en
fait partie le deuxième élément qu'en
fait partie c'est la mesure des débits
de ventilation en bouche
bouge d'extraction et la vitesse du
ventilateur ça ça ne coûte pas très cher
mais déjà on constaterait si le la
ventilation fonctionne donc il y a des
mesures qui peuvent être faites en
existant et qui font d'abord qu'ils font
d'ailleurs l'objet des labels BBC
rénovation de définirgies qui sont
écrits depuis des années avec le
processus d'opération les gens sont du
manque formés pour faire ces contrôles
là il y a des opérateurs de la mesure
qui sont certifiés et qualifiées par la
par une commission en charge de la
réglementation donc les dispositifs
existent il suffit simplement de les
adjoindre aux aides et là encore ce sera
souverain
parce que mesurer des débits de
ventilation c'est très facile mais
encore faut-il conditionner les aides à
l'isol à la ventilation avec la mesure à
la fin les aides à l'isolation avec la
mesure étanchéité à l'air les aides à la
menuiserie avec ça en Réno global
faisons une ligne effectivement sur les
mesures qui sont efficaces pour la fin
des chantiers
alors il y avait ce qui est fait en
Allemagne sur monsieur dans les systèmes
d'aide à la rénovation en Allemagne
notamment soutenu par laquelle W il y a
un contrôle à chacun d'opération 1 sur
les l'ensemble des éléments de preuves
de tous les équipements qui sont
installés c'est-à-dire tous les
marquages de tous les équipements le
deuxième sur l'étanchéité à l'air des
bâtiments et le troisième a suivi des
consommations énergétiques pendant trois
ans et ça fonctionne
est-ce que le sujet mériterait pas à
partir de des choses très concrètes que
vous venez d'évoquer une réglementation
spécifique mais la réglementation existe
monsieur il suffit simplement que les
aides soient conditionnées aux mesures
prévues par cette réglementation
tout existe tout écrit vous avez même
des entreprises qui sont qualifiées
certifiés les méthodologies existent
tout existe tout existe tout est
disponible au niveau des aides on dise
voilà au lieu de mettre 1500 euros pour
une maîtrise d'oeuvre d'accompagnateur
rénov on dit voilà faire une mesure
d'étanchéité à l'air dans une maison
même quand on est en rase campagne c'est
600 euros
quand vous quand vous êtes quand vous en
faites plusieurs vous pouvez avoir des
forfaits à 350 euros la maison
la mesure de débit de ventilation existe
aussi c'est écrit dans les dispositifs
de tous les labels et de toutes les
certifications
donc la garantie ou c'est ce que c'est
que la garantie de résultats de
performance
aller sur le site et synergie.org vous
le trouvez sur le site de l'association
HQ vous le trouvez aussi et donc
effectivement alloué à une maison mille
ou 1500 euros pour un audit énergétique
et les mesures d'étanchéité à l'air et
de ventilation qui sont d'ailleurs des
mesures en faveur de la qualité de l'air
des occupés et la qualité de vie des
occupants ça serait extrêmement
pertinent évidemment plus que de donner
1500 euros pour la maîtrise d'oeuvre qui
n'arrivera pas à se faire mais qui n'est
pas à la hauteur de toute manière de ce
qu'il faut faire dans ce cas là alors on
va essayer de pas trop et fille et puis
Elliot peut-être peut-être si elle mais
très rapidement parce qu'on a une
audition de véritable ronde sur
l'outre-mer et on a des gens qui sont en
visio donc on voudrait pas trop les
faire attendre très rapidement je pense
que pour donner une petite lueur
d'optimisme là-dedans je pense que la
garantie de performante ça va être une
garantie d'étiquette demain quand vous
allez avoir l'obligation d'être sur une
étiquette des
CAP dans le cadre des dispositifs
immobiliers pour pouvoir louer ou demain
peut-être vendre votre bien en tout cas
louer ça c'est déjà le cas dans la loi
vous allez être en mesure d'être en
exigence avec l'entreprise et en tout
cas nous on s'attend à ce qu'il y a des
sept exigences-là de la part des clients
de dire en fait moi je veux à la sortie
des travaux d'être dans l'étiquette des
pour pouvoir louer mon bien donc quelque
part vous allez avoir un système d'offre
et de demande qui va qui va faire en
sorte que vous allez devoir prouver
cette sortie de passoire et demain cette
étiquette énergétique donc c'est bien la
demande qui va tirer l'offre sur cette
engagement sur la performance
tout a été à peu près dit je vais juste
rajouter le fait que la formation est
quand même le maître mot et la clé du
succès de cette politique publique de
rénovation énergétique je suis allé voir
le Conseil supérieur du notarial la
semaine dernière
vous avez positionné il y a un travail
absolument incroyable dans les études
juste pour sensibiliser à la
réglementation auprès des notaires c'est
quand même eux qui sont en contact avec
la population on le voit également pour
les élus des communes rurales ils n'ont
pas forcément
les services Directeur Général des
Services directeur général des services
techniques pour s'occuper de ces
questions là donc comment est-ce qu'on
leur apporte la connaissance les
journalistes aujourd'hui on voit
beaucoup de dossiers sur la fraude oui
il existe de la fraude mais qu'est-ce
qu'il se fait de bien comment est-ce
qu'on peut prêcher la bonne parole tout
ça on a besoin de faire comprendre
d'expliquer de former d'informer et la
clé c'est la formation les artisans
des services d'accompagnement
les mares tout ça ça demande de la
formation du personnel étant qu'on aura
pas réglé cette problématique là je
pense qu'on sera on n'arrivera pas à
solutionner la question donc voilà merci
beaucoup
ça va dans le même sens je pense que une
des clés c'est de conditionner l'octroi
des aides ou en tout cas de la plupart
des aides à cette mesure de d'efficacité
alors après je rejoins ce qui a été dit
les cahiers des charges ou les
méthodologies de mesure peuvent exister
mais elles sont encore
un peu en méthode indirecte donc je
pense qu'il y a encore un effort de de
structuration pour établir des règles de
l'art en termes de mesure de performance
énergétique et en intégrant le le timing
parce que mesurer la performance
énergétique pour une entreprise quand
c'est intégrée dans un dans un contrat
de performance énergétique
c'est possible de rémunérer après
plusieurs années sur les économies
d'énergie pour un ménage et avec les
avances que font aussi les entreprises
du bâtiment c'est un peu plus compliqué
donc il faut avoir un cahier des charges
et des règles de l'art qui permettent
d'anticiper ces mesures de de
d'efficacité énergétique l'économie
d'énergie
écoutez merci beaucoup pour ces échanges
qui ont été très intéressants si vous
avez des contributions
supplémentaires à nous faire remonter
jusque au secrétariat de la commission
d'enquête c'est toujours avec intérêt et
puis on vous souhaite une bonne soirée
merci de nous avoir consacré ces deux
heures d'échanges merci beaucoup